You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye. and health conditions at early stages.
你知道的，你的眼睛经历了很多。每天阅读、处于昏暗光线中、看屏幕时间太长，这些情况我经常遇到。开车时刺眼的阳光直射眼睛。甚至夜间驾驶也会导致眼部疲劳。所以，是的，我们的眼睛承受了很大的负荷。因此，照顾好它们，并通过定期眼科检查监测眼睛健康非常重要。在 Specsavers 进行 99 美元起的眼科检查来检查眼部健康，其中包含 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于在早期阶段检测眼部和健康状况。
To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you.
要查找您附近的门店并预约 99 美元起的 OCT 扫描眼科检查，请访问 Specsavers。眼科检查由独立的验光师提供。价格可能因门店而异。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极《办公室》重温播客。
Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi, everybody. Well, hello, hello. What is this energy? I don't know. I brought my roller skates today. Oh, this is roller skate energy. Uh-huh, uh-huh. You said you were going to do this. I'm skating through the new office. I want to show it to you guys. You might remember Angela skated through Earwolf and when we came in here for a meeting, she noticed the floors were good for roller skating again. So like any 53-year-old, I brought my roller skates. And you're going to roller skate today. Just a middle-aged lady skating through her office. Well, this is what you're
每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享独家幕后故事，这些故事只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你。我们是 Office Ladies。大家好。哦，哈喽哈喽。这是什么活力？我不知道。我今天带了旱冰鞋。哦，这就是旱冰鞋的活力。嗯哼，嗯哼。你之前说过你要这么做。我在新办公室里滑冰。我想把它展示给你们看。你们可能还记得安吉拉在 Earwolf 滑过冰，当我们来到这里开会时，她发现这里的地板又很适合滑冰了。所以就像任何一个53岁的人一样，我带来了旱冰鞋。你今天要滑旱冰。一个中年妇女在她的办公室里滑冰。好吧，这就是你
bringing today, and I like it. I'm here for it. Well, thank you. Guess what we're talking about today? Starmageddon. It's season 9, episode 20, written by Dan Sterling, and directed by Matt Sown. Matt Sown sent in some wonderful director's perspective audio clips on this. He's just the best. I know we've said this, but the other day, I was at the grocery store, and I ran into him, and I was getting takeout, and I had all these bags. And Matt was like, Angela, what are you doing? And he walked across the parking lot, scooped up my bags, and walked me to my car.
今天带来的东西，我很喜欢。我支持这个。谢谢。猜猜我们今天在聊什么？《史塔末日》。这是第九季第二十集，由丹·斯特林编剧，马特·索恩执导。马特·索恩为此发来了一些精彩的导演视角音频剪辑。他真的是最棒的。我知道我们说过这话，但有一天，我在杂货店偶遇了他，当时我在买外卖，手里提着各种袋子。马特说，安吉拉，你在干什么？然后他穿过停车场，帮我拎起袋子，一直送我到车前。
You know, we describe every person as the best, but it's because they are. I know. We were so fortunate. We were. All right, everyone, here's your summary for Starmageddon. The building's elevator is being repaired. And Stanley is not pleased. He refuses to use the stairs.
你知道的，我们把每个人都形容为最棒的，但那是因为他们确实如此。我知道。我们太幸运了。我们确实很幸运。好了，各位，以下是《史塔末日》的剧情梗概。大楼的电梯正在维修。斯坦利很不高兴。他拒绝走楼梯。
It's a whole thing. Dwight has to use some unconventional tactics to force Stanley to join him on a sales call. And the first newspaper review of the documentary is published. Yeah. This is going to lead to a lot of things, including Angela having to publicly defend Senator Lipton. Meanwhile, Toby and Nellie act as sort of sounding boards, surrogate therapists for Jim and Pam's relationship. Yeah, sort of relationship guides, these two. Nellie and Toby.
这可真是一件大事。德怀特不得不使用一些非常规的手段来强迫斯坦利和他一起去拜访客户。纪录片的的第一篇报纸评论发表了。是的。这将引发一系列事情，包括安吉拉不得不公开为利普顿参议员辩护。与此同时，托比和内莉扮演某种倾听者、吉姆和帕姆关系的代孕治疗师。是的，有点像关系向导，这两个人。内莉和托比。
Yeah. Interesting choice. And yet, worked out. Yet, like some real nuggets there. Yeah. All right, everyone, for today's top of show, I'm going to kick things off with a fan question from Caitlin G in Milton, Florida. Caitlin said, I have been waiting over four years to send this note.
是的。有趣的选择。然而，结果却很不错。而且其中还包含一些真正的干货。是的。好了，各位，今天的节目开头，我将以来自佛罗里达州米尔顿的凯特琳·G的一个粉丝提问来拉开序幕。凯特琳说，我等了四年多才发这封信。
Stair McGidden is my favorite episode of the office and possibly my favorite episode of television of all time. Caitlin, you love this one. Loves it. Caitlin says the image of Stanley sliding down the stairs, wearing that silly helmet and wrapped in bubble wrap makes me laugh to the point of tears every time I watch it. Every time I've had a bad day or needed to pick me up,
《楼梯末日》是我最喜欢的《办公室》剧集，也可能是我有生以来最喜欢的电视节目。凯特琳，你太爱这一集了。太喜欢了。凯特琳说，每次看斯坦利戴着那顶愚蠢的头盔、裹着气泡膜滑下楼梯的画面，我都笑得流泪。每当我度过糟糕的一天或者需要振作起来时，
I put on this episode. It has been a bright spot through my PPD, my husband's military deployments, and a cross-country move with two toddlers during the pandemic. Caitlin, my goodness. I know. Caitlin said, I truly can't explain what a gift this particular episode has been to my life and how excited I am to hear y'all break it down. You two and your team are a joy to listen to you.
我就会播放这一集。它一直是我产后抑郁期间、我丈夫服兵役期间以及在疫情期间带着两个幼儿跨国搬家期间的一束光。凯特琳，天哪。我知道。凯特琳说，我真的无法形容这一集对我的生命来说是多么珍贵的礼物，我也无法形容听到你们剖析它时我是多么兴奋。你们两个和你们的团队听起来真让人开心。
Thanks for putting such a positive, cozy thing out into the world. Ah, well, I'm so glad that this episode has brought you so much joy and I hope that our breakdown of it will bring you more joy. Same. I mean, Caitlin, you drove cross-country with two toddlers. I know. And to have your husband deployed? Yeah. that's a lot to hold. Yeah. We got another fan question about this episode from Kindle W in Phoenix,
感谢你们向世界传递如此积极、温暖的东西。啊，好吧，我很高兴这一集给你带来了这么多的快乐，我希望我们对它的剖析能给你带来更多的快乐。我也是。我是说，凯特琳，你带着两个幼儿跨国开车。我知道。还要面对你丈夫去服役？是的，这要承受的东西太多了。是的。我们收到了另一个关于这一集的粉丝提问，来自亚利桑那州凤凰城的肯德尔·W，
Arizona, who said, please tell me Leslie David Baker will be a guest for this episode. I loved his storyline. Well, Kendall, I am very excited because I have been holding on to this for months, for months. Okay, so a while back, me and Leslie and Phyllis did a Cheerios commercial. We did a few. You're probably seeing them now. They were directed by Zach Woods, phenomenal director, and he's so smart and funny. But the four of us on set together, it was like old times. We were laughing so hard. I have all these pictures of us just cracking up between scenes. And we had lunch together on set, Jenna. Oh my gosh. It was so crazy because you were doing like a mini office reunion commercial. And then I was doing a mini office reunion
她说，请告诉我莱斯利·大卫·贝克会作为这一集的嘉宾。我喜欢他的故事线。好吧，肯德尔，我非常兴奋，因为这件事我憋了好几个月，好几个月了。好吧，所以不久前，我和莱斯利还有菲利斯拍了一个 Cheerios 麦片广告。我们拍了好几个。你们现在可能已经看到了。它们是由扎克·伍兹执导的，他是一位杰出的导演，而且他非常聪明有趣。我们四个人一起在片场，感觉就像旧时光一样。我们笑得太厉害了。我有我们之间在片场休息时笑得前仰后合的所有照片。我们在片场一起吃了午餐，珍娜。哦，天哪。这太疯狂了，因为你当时在拍一个迷你的《办公室》重聚广告。然后我也在拍一个迷你的《办公室》重聚
commercial at the same time. We were in two different cities and it was so crazy. Yes. And Jenna, while you were doing your commercial, I was actually in St. Louis, which made me think of you even more because not only am I with the castmates. But anyway, we were at lunch one day and it was me and Leslie and I turned to Leslie and I'm like, Leslie, we have got to hear from you on office ladies about your time on the office. And he was like, let's do it now. And I was like, right now. And I was like, okay. I grabbed my phone and he specifically talked about this episode. So he was like, let's do it now. And I was like, okay. I was like, I grabbed my phone. And he specifically talked about this episode. So he. Here is my lunch break interview on my cell phone with Leslie David Baker. It is delightful. Hello, office ladies, listeners. I am sitting here on the set of our new Cheerios commercial with Phyllis and Leslie. And Leslie's right here next to me. Yay.
广告，就在同时。我们在两个不同的城市，这太疯狂了。是的。珍娜，当你在拍广告的时候，我其实在圣路易斯，这让我更加想念你，因为我不仅和演员们在一起。不管怎样，有一天我们在吃午餐，当时是我和莱斯利，我转向莱斯利说，莱斯利，我们一定要在 Office Ladies 上听你讲讲你在《办公室》的日子。他说，我们现在就录吧。我说，就在现在？他说，好吧。我拿出了手机，他专门谈到了这一集。所以他说，我们现在就录吧。我说，好吧。我说，我拿出了手机。他专门谈到了这一集。所以。这是我在手机上对莱斯利·大卫·贝克的午餐休息采访。非常愉快。你好，Office Ladies 的听众们。我正坐在我们新的 Cheerios 麦片广告片场，和菲利斯以及莱斯利在一起。莱斯利就在我旁边。耶。
I'm here. Hi. How's everybody? Right now, Leslie's eating a really cute sugar cookie with a bumblebee on it. And we just had lunch. And Leslie, here are my office ladies questions for you. All right. Shoot.
我在这里。嗨。大家怎么样？现在，莱斯利正在吃一块带有大黄蜂图案的非常可爱的糖霜饼干。我们刚吃完午餐。莱斯利，这是我为你准备的 Office Ladies 问题。好的。问吧。
How did you get your job on the office? I got my job on the office. Allison Jones called me in and said that she wanted me to audition for a show called The Office based upon the British version. I had never watched it, but heard it was successful. Went to the first audition, had on a very nice press, shirt, suit, tie was looking very elegant and dapper.
你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？我得到了《办公室》的工作。艾莉森·琼斯打电话叫我去试镜一个基于英国版改编的名为《办公室》的节目。我从未看过它，但听说它很成功。去了第一次试听，穿着一件非常整洁挺括的衬衫、西装、领带，看起来非常优雅绅士。
Did the audition. She told me, said, okay, I want you to go to the callback, but when you go to the callback, don't go in looking as crisp and pressed as you are. You want to come in looking kind of slumpy and kind of, you know, shirt, wrinkled, disheveled,
完成了试镜。她告诉我，说，好吧，我希望你去参加复试，但当你去复试时，不要像现在这样看起来那么清爽挺括。你得看起来有点无精打采，有点，你知道的，衬衫起皱、衣衫不整的，
because you are at this paper company and you've been there for quite a time, and you really don't want to be there. So I went to the audition, I got to the callback audition. I had another audition that day for another project. And when I got to the office audition, there were about 50, 75 people there.
因为你在一家纸业公司呆了很长时间，而你其实并不想呆在那里。所以我去参加了试镜，进入了复试。那天我还有一个试镜是关于另一个项目的。当我到办公室试镜时，那里大约有50、75个人。
It was very crowded room. And I looked and I thought, so, wait a minute, all these people are ahead of me. I have time to go to my other audition. Hopped in the car, left, went to the other audition. On the way back, ran into a lot of traffic and ambulances and school buses and every senior citizen in the free world. driving. So when I got back, I got to sit down and do my reading with Phyllis Smith.
房间非常拥挤。我看了看，心想，等等，所有这些人都在我前面。我有时间去参加另一个试镜。跳进车里，离开，去了另一个试镜。在回来的路上，遇到了很多交通堵塞、救护车、校车，以及自由世界里每一个开着车的老年人。所以当我回来时，我坐下来和菲利斯·史密斯一起读剧本。
Allison Jones said, oh, Leslie, thank you so much for being patient and waiting. They said you were in the restroom, you know, and I just went, oh, yeah, okay. No, my pleasure. I didn't mind waiting at all. And sat down, read with Phyllis. Greg Daniels told us, when you finish the scene on the paper, just keep going. He wanted us to do some improv. So I did. So I incorporated what I had just gone through driving through rush hour traffic with Phyllis, and Phyllis was speeding me all the, you know, good vibes that she was feeding me. And we bantered back and forth. And we looked up and the people at the casting table were laughing and, you know, cut me off and said, okay, thank you. And I went outside. Allison gave me two thumbs up.
艾莉森·琼斯说，哦，莱斯利，非常感谢你的耐心等待。他们说你在洗手间，你知道的，我当时就说，哦，是的，好的。不，不用谢。我一点也不介意等。然后坐下来，和菲利斯一起读剧本。格雷格·丹尼尔斯告诉我们，当你在纸上完成这一幕时，继续演下去。他想让我们做一些即兴表演。所以我照做了。所以我把刚刚经历的顶着晚高峰交通开车的经历融入其中，而菲利斯则把她传递给我的所有美好氛围都带给我。我们一来一回地开玩笑。我们抬头一看，选角桌旁的人都在笑，然后打断我说，好的，谢谢。我走出去了。艾莉森对我竖起了两个大拇指。
And I thought, you know, okay, she's just a sweet, loving, positive person. And I probably won't hear anything. A few weeks later, I got a call, and next thing I knew, they said, you booked it. So getting stuck in traffic kind of helped your audition. It helped a lot. And then after I booked it, then my agent announced to me that he was retiring from show business and turning his agency over to his best friend. And I went, oh, okay, no problem. And then while I was waiting to hear what happens with the office, the agency switched over to his best friend who had a heart attack and died. Oh, my gosh. A week later, I got a call from NBC saying that they were picking the show up, and then SAG
我想，你知道的，好吧，她只是一个甜美、有爱心、积极的人。我可能不会听到任何消息。几周后，我接到一个电话，接下来我知道的时候，他们说，你拿下了这个角色。所以被堵在路上反而帮了你的试镜。很有帮助。在我拿下角色后，我的经纪人宣布他要从娱乐圈退休，并将他的经纪公司转交给他的最好朋友。我说，哦，好的，没问题。然后，当我等待《办公室》的消息时，经纪公司转给了他最好的朋友，结果那个人心脏病发作去世了。哦，天哪。一周后，我接到NBC的电话，说他们要续订这部剧，然后SAG
called me and said that I didn't have to pay an agent 10% because there was no agent to pay, and we did, I think, six more episodes, and then it kept going, and voila. Wow. I had never heard that story before. Okay, let's see. Next question. Do you have a favorite episode from your time on the show? The favorite one was I think when Dwight, Rayne Wilson, you know,
打电话给我，说我不用付给经纪人10%的佣金，因为没有经纪人可付，我们大概拍了六集，然后它就继续播下去，就这样。哇。我以前从没听过这个故事。好吧，让我们看看。下一个问题。你在剧组期间有没有最喜欢的剧集？我最喜欢的应该是当德怀特，也就是雷恩·威尔逊，你知道的，
shoots me with the blow dart. And then he and Clark, they roll me up in bubble wrap and slide me down the stairs, and roll me across the parking lot to go to a staff meeting. That was a fun one. That wasn't really me sliding down the stairs. They had this mannequin made, and I figured if I was going to look that bad dead, I probably would be cremated. But that was a fun episode. So if anybody ever offers to wrap you in bubble wrap and roll you across the pavement, let them it's very comfortable.
用吹箭射我。然后他和克拉克把我裹在气泡膜里，让我顺着楼梯滑下去，再把我滚过停车场去开员工会议。那是一个有趣的镜头。那真的不是我顺着楼梯滑下去的。他们做了一个这样的假人，我想如果我死得那么难看，我大概会被火化。但那是一集有趣的剧集。所以如果有人曾经提议把你裹在气泡膜里并在人行道上把你滚过去，答应他们吧，这非常舒服。
Oh, we had a fan ask, did you ever actually do a crossword? I started many, many crossword puzzles, and everybody in the office would come by. and scribble in my crossword puzzle book, a few lines. I never got through a single solitary crossword puzzle book the entire nine-year run because the paper gets flimsy after a while. So they replaced those books and then auctioned them, raffle them off, gave them a wave to charity. Do you have one? Were you able to keep one?
哦，有粉丝问，你真的做过填字游戏吗？我开始了许许多多的填字游戏，办公室里的每个人都会过来，在我的填字游戏书上乱涂几行。在长达九年的播出期间，我从来没有通读过哪怕一本孤立的填字游戏书，因为过了一会儿纸变薄了。所以他们换了那些书，然后拿去拍卖，进行抽奖，把它们作为慈善事业捐出去。你有一本吗？你留下一本了吗？
I've got one. Yeah, one. One. I think one or two. But the whole concept of Stanley doing the crossword puzzle, I came up with that. when Greg Daniel said, you're going into a staff meeting, what could you do in that meeting to show that you were in the meeting but not at the meeting? And I looked around in the drawers of, you know, we had a bunch of stuff from the prop house.
我有一本。是的，一本。一本。我想有一两本。但斯坦利做填字游戏整个概念是我提出的。当格雷格·丹尼尔斯说，你要去开一个员工会议，在那个会议上你能做什么来表明你人在会议中但心不在焉？我四处看了看抽屉，你知道的，我们有很多来自道具仓库的东西。
And I came across this old crossword puzzle book. And it was already filled out, but on camera, it didn't matter. So I did that. And I said, I'm going to deliver my line. I had a couple of lines to Steve Carell, instead of speaking directly, to him, I just delivered the lines but didn't look up from the crossword puzzle book. I figured if they didn't like it, you know, then, you know, I think Greg was directing that episode. I said, if he doesn't like that, I did that, he'll change it. He loved it. And Stanley and the crossword puzzle
我偶然发现了这本旧的填字游戏书。它已经填满了，但在镜头前，这并不重要。所以我这么做了。我说，我要说出我的台词。我对史蒂夫·卡瑞尔有几句台词，我没有直接对着他说话，我只是说出台词，但视线没有从填字游戏书上抬起来。我想如果他们不喜欢，你知道的，那么，你知道的，我想格雷格在导演那一集。我说，如果他不喜欢我这么做，他会改掉的。他很喜欢。于是斯坦利和填字游戏
was born. I love that. I love it. Okay. Last question. When the show wrapped, did you take anything from the set? Oh, my gosh. I have my original wedding band. I have my Thunder, Mifflin, Thermos, Body. I've got some couple of mugs. I've got a couple of some of the sports cars off of my little cars. Oh, all your little cars? I've got, I think, a nameplate and some other little odds and ends. You know, didn't take the clothes because, you know, they're not. Yeah, I didn't take any clothes either.
就这样诞生了。我喜欢那样。我太喜欢了。好吧。最后一个问题。节目杀青时，你从片场拿了什么东西吗？哦，天哪。我有我原来的结婚戒指。我有我的邓德米夫林保温杯，身体。我有几个杯子。我有一些我小车上的小跑车。哦，你所有的那些小车？我有，我想，一个名牌和其他一些零七八碎的小东西。你知道的，没有拿衣服，因为，你知道的，它们不是。是的，我也没有拿任何衣服。
The clothes were not anything that I would wear in real life. But yeah, that was it. All right. Thank you so much, Leslie. You're welcome. Talking to me on our lunch break. You're welcome. Anytime.
这些衣服并不是我在现实生活中会穿的款式。不过是的，就是这样。好了。非常感谢你，莱斯利。不客气。在我们的午休时间跟我聊天。不客气。随时奉陪。
Angela, I loved it. I was so excited. You texted me and you said, Leslie said I can interview him right now. And I was like, do it, do it. I don't care that I'm not there. Just do it. And it was, I couldn't believe he brought up Starmageddon.
安吉拉，我太喜欢了。我太兴奋了。你给我发短信说，莱斯利说我可以现在采访他。当时我就想，快去，快去。我不在乎我当时不在那儿。就这么做。而且，我简直不敢相信他提到了“星际大战末日”。
I know. Which we hadn't gotten to yet. And I was so excited. Yes. And I knew when we got to this episode, it would be the perfect time to play his interview. Oh, well, I think now we've interviewed all of the main cast members. How fitting. I love that. Mm-hmm. Oh, and Leslie, thanks so much for on your lunch break, chatting with me.
我知道。我们当时还没聊到那一集。我太兴奋了。是的。而且我知道当我们聊到这一集时，将是播放他采访的最佳时机。哦，好吧，我想现在我们已经采访了所有主要演员。真是太合适了。我太喜欢了。嗯哼。哦，莱斯利，非常感谢你在午休时间跟我聊天。
Well, once again, I have to say, he's the best. He is the best. All right, well, let's take a break, and when we come back, we'll break down Steremageddon, along with those great audio clips from director Matt Zone. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Yeah. Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in.
好吧，我得再次说，他是最棒的。他真的是最棒的。好吧，我们休息一下，回来后，我们将剖析“星际大战末日”，以及来自导演马特·佐恩的那些精彩音频剪辑。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，仅仅因为这是新的一年，并不意味着你必须成为一个崭新的自己。但也许你想成为一个负担更轻、思路更清晰的自己。是的。不是一个完全崭新的自己，但也许就像你想专注于某些方面。
You want to refine. Yeah. I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down, what might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationship. your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things.
你想提炼升华。是的。我喜欢这个。提炼。嗯，心理治疗可以帮助更容易地识别是什么让你感到沉重，是什么可能在阻碍你。你可以更好地了解你的关系。你的动机，你的情绪。我正试图放下对小事情的压力。
Mm-hmm. Because those really just add up. Mm-hmm. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things. Mm-hmm. BetterHelp therapists can help. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, h-elp.com slash office ladies. This episode is going to start with Stanley.
嗯哼。因为那些真的会积少成多。嗯哼。而且一切都会好起来的。嗯，你可能需要帮助来识别什么是小事，什么是大事。嗯哼。BetterHelp的治疗师可以提供帮助。BetterHelp拥有超过3万名治疗师，是全球最大的在线治疗平台，已为全球500多万人提供服务。BetterHelp让你轻松在网上与合格的治疗师进行匹配。注册并在 betterhelp.com/office ladies 上享受 9 折优惠。网址是 betterh-elp.com/office ladies。这一集将从斯坦利开始。
He's arriving to work and he realizes the elevators are out of order. He is not happy about it. Aaron's going to arrive and she's real peppy. She's like, come on, Stanley, this is Starmageddon. You got this. Yeah, she kind of reminds him. Dwight has been prepping us for this for a while. He's had signs.
他到公司上班，突然发现电梯坏了。他很不高兴。艾伦到的时候精神抖擞。她就像是，来吧，斯坦利，这是“电梯末日”。你可以的。对，她有点提醒他。德怀特为这事已经准备好一阵子了。他还立了牌子。
He put like a wooden staircase at reception for people to practice. Yeah. Erin has this hilarious talking head to me where she says, Dwight really wanted everyone to prepare mentally and physically for a day that hopefully will only come once every hundred years. Because it's a Magdalen. Yeah. The elevator is only going to need maintenance once every hundred years.
他在前台摆了个木楼梯让大家练习。对。艾琳有个特别搞笑的单人访谈，她说德怀特真的很想让大家在精神和身体上为这样一个日子做好准备，这个日子希望每百年才发生一次。因为这是“电梯末日”。对。电梯每百年才需要维护一次。
But also, Aaron is suggesting that the word Armageddon means every 100 years. Yes, I know. You know, Angela, I appreciated Dwight's prepping for this Stramageddon. You know I love prepping. You really do. And in particular, you love prepping for worst case scenarios. Well, I have a story. My sister came out recently with her kids.
不过，艾伦还在暗示“末日”这个词的意思是每100年一次。对，我知道。你知道吗，安吉拉，我很欣赏德怀特为这次“电梯末日”所做的准备。你知道我喜欢做准备。你确实很喜欢。而且特别是，你喜欢为最坏的情况做准备。好吧，我有个故事。我姐姐最近带着她的孩子们来了。
And while all the cousins were playing together, my sister and I did some, like, deep cleaning organization of my stuff. I saw the pictures. You guys did some deep, deep organization and cleaning. Okay. well, I helped her with her house last time I was there, and so she was returning the favor. This is one of my new favorite sister bonding things we do. I was going to say, this is true sister stuff. It's like when my sister flew out here and helped me pack my house when I moved.
当所有的表兄弟姐妹们在一块玩的时候，我和我姐姐对我的东西进行了一些深度清理和收纳。我看到照片了。你们俩做了非常非常深度的收纳和清理。好吧，我上次去她家时帮了她，所以她这是在礼尚往来。这是我最近最喜欢的姐妹培养感情的方式之一。我正想说，这太像亲姐妹会做的事了。就像我搬家时我姐姐飞来这里帮我打包房子一样。
Yes. Yes. Exactly. Okay. So this one cabinet that we were going through, it's a giant cabinet, and it's full of all of my extra office ladies merch, office merch. It's things that if someone's having a charity event or there's someone's. someone special, I need to send something to, I go to this cabinet. Sure. Well, my sister was like, let's organize this. Like, let's put all the shirts together and all the mugs together and the signed
对。对。没错。好吧。所以我们正在整理的这个柜子，是个巨大的柜子，里面装满了所有我多余的“办公室辣妈”周边、办公室周边。都是如果有人办慈善活动，或者有某个人，某个特殊的人，我需要送点东西时，我会去这个柜子拿。当然。好吧，我姐姐就说，我们把这个整理一下吧。比如，把所有的衬衫放在一起，所有的杯子放在一起，还有签名的
things together. I'm like, this is really helpful. But then she was like, what are these backpacks in here? And I was like, oh, I'm like, those are my worst case scenario backpacks, you know, like for the zombie apocalypse or a natural disaster or whatever. Mixed in with your office merch, that was your zombie apocalypse kit. She was like, why are they? there's so many. Can't we, can we consolidate them? And I'm like, Emily, no, you can't consolidate them because they have to be light enough that you can grab and run. You have to run with these things on your back. And if one pack is way too heavy, it's like they all have to be light enough that each member of the family can grab one and then bolt. Okay? She was like, okay. And she's like,
东西放在一起。我说，这真的很有帮助。但接着她就问，这里面这些背包是什么？我就说，哦，我说，那是我的“最坏情况”背包，你知道的，比如为了僵尸末日、自然灾害什么的。跟你的办公室周边混在一起，那居然是你的僵尸末日急救包。她就说，它们怎么……有这么多？难道我们不能，不能把它们合并一下吗？我说，艾米丽，不行，你不能合并它们，因为它们必须足够轻，你才能抓起来就跑。你得背着这些东西逃跑。如果一个背包太重，就好像它们必须都足够轻，这样家庭的每个成员都能抓起一个然后马上开溜。好吧？她说，好吧。然后她说，
but this one you're barely using. I'm like, that one has a solar panel in it for charging things. It's very important. She's like, this one is what's the same? one. I'm like, that's food. How many do you have? Four. Four. Would you like more? Be honest. Well, I would, but honestly, like I said, you've got to be able to grab and carry it. Travel light. And here's the other thing. They have to be packed in such a way that if you lose one, it's not like one bag is all medical supplies. Because what if you lose that one? You're out. All your you have to spread it out. Right. So all of that to say was that. this was really my sister's first time being confronted with this part of me was this discussion and reveal of these backpacks. Your preparedness kits?
但这个你几乎没用过。我说，那个里面有块太阳能电池板，用来给设备充电。这非常重要。她说，那这个呢，这个是干嘛的？我说，那是食物。你有几个？四个。四个。你还想要更多吗？说实话。好吧，我是想，但老实说，就像我说的，你得拿得动、背得走。轻装出行。还有一件事。它们的打包方式必须是，如果你弄丢了一个，不会说刚好一个包里装的全是医疗用品。因为如果你把那个弄丢了怎么办？你就完蛋了。你所有的，你得分散开来。对。所以总而言之，这真的是我姐姐第一次面对我这部分性格，就是通过这次讨论和这些背包的曝光。你的应急准备包？
Yeah. That I'm proud of. And I asked Lee once, I said, do you think I'm crazy? And he said, time will tell. Well, he loves your kind of crazy, so it doesn't matter. Can I ask what's in the kits? Oh gosh, of course, Sam. Yes.
对。我为此感到骄傲。我曾经问过李，我说，你觉得我疯了吗？他说，时间会证明一切的。好吧，他爱你的这种疯狂，所以这不重要。我能问问急救包里都有什么吗？哦天哪，当然了，萨姆。是的。
As someone who doesn't have one, but is, I know. I know. Sam, I have one earthquake kit, but I don't know where it is. Okay. So you don't have one. So I don't have one. Also, if you haven't updated it lately, you don't have one. Okay, so what you need is, was that preparedness sass?
作为身边的朋友，虽然我自己没有，但我知道。我知道。萨姆，我有一个地震急救包，但我不知道它放哪儿了。好吧。所以你没有。所以我没有。另外，如果你最近没有更新它，那你等于没有。好吧，所以你需要的是，那是对应急准备的吐槽吗？
It might have been a little bit preparedness sass. Here's what's in them. So you're going to need food. Mm-hmm. Okay. Okay. Like space food, though. Like in little packets that you don't need to heat up.
这可能有点对应急准备的吐槽。以下是里面的东西。所以你需要食物。嗯哼。好吧。好吧。不过像是太空食品。比如那种不需要加热的小包装里装的。
Right. Yeah. Space food. Next. Then you're going to need a way to create clean water. Oh. Okay. Okay.
对。没错。太空食品。接下来。然后你需要一种获取干净水的方法。哦。好吧。好吧。
You're going to need goggles, masks, those like silver blankets that keep you warm. Like after I run a marathon? Yes. Right. You need all these things. You're going to want extra pair of underwear, extra pair of socks. You're going to need medicines. You're going to want some pet food if you plan on fleeing.
你需要护目镜、口罩、那种能帮你保暖的银色毯子。就像我跑完马拉松之后那种？对。没错。你需要所有这些东西。你会想要备用内衣、备用袜子。你需要药物。如果你打算带着宠物逃亡，你还会想要一些宠物食品。
with your animals. Why do we have the feeling Angela's is all roller skates and snacks? You're not wrong. Throw in a little bit of rosé. I think that's two solid approaches. Yeah, me too. Okay. I'll skate over to you for medicine and you can have some of my rosé. I love this. I didn't pack any rosé. I'll need it. All right, well, listen back to this episode. Aaron is trying to coach Stanley to get up the stairs. He really, it's like he's never seen a stare in his life. I loved the scene description for this episode because it said, quote, a couple of people from other offices and a sparklets guy with a bottle on his shoulder passed Stanley on their way up. Stanley tries to grab their coattails, but they shrug him off.
为什么我们会有种感觉，安吉拉的急救包里全都是旱冰鞋和小零食？你没猜错。再加一点桃红葡萄酒。我觉得这是两个扎实的处理方式。对，我也是。好吧。我会踩着溜冰鞋去找你拿药，然后你可以分我一点桃红葡萄酒。我太喜欢了。我没带任何桃红葡萄酒。我会需要的。好吧，让我们回到这一集。艾伦正试图指导斯坦利上楼梯。他真的，就好像他这辈子没见过楼梯一样。我超爱这一集的场景描述，因为它写道，“引用，其他办公室的几个人和一个扛着水桶的斯帕克利茨送水工在他们上楼时从斯坦利身边经过。斯坦利试图抓住他们的衣角，但他们耸耸肩把他甩开了。”
Well, now Andy is going to burst into the bullpen. It's a red alert because his brother texted him that the Scranton Times Tribune.com had released a review of the documentary. I needed to check the script on this one. I wanted to know if it was scripted for Andy to come from the bathroom with his red alert. Did you notice he comes out of the men's room? Yeah. It was actually scripted for him to just come out of the kitchen. It's funnier than he came out of the men's room. I agree. He was like checking his phone in the bathroom. I loved that detail. Well, now everyone is going to start to read the review. It starts with Oscar, then goes to Nelly and Aaron, and I felt like we should read it. Okay, great. Oscar says, The Office, an American
好吧，现在安迪要闯入办公区了。这是红色警报，因为他弟弟发短信说《斯克兰顿纪事论坛报》网站发布了一篇对这部纪录片的评论。我得查一下这一集的剧本。我想知道剧本里是不是写了安迪要从洗手间出来并发布红色警报。你注意到他是从男洗手间出来的吗？对。剧本里其实是写他从厨房出来。他从男洗手间出来更有趣。我同意。他在洗手间里刷手机呢。我太喜欢这个细节了。好吧，现在每个人都要开始读这篇评论了。从奥斯卡开始，然后传给奈莉和艾伦，我觉得我们应该读一下。好的，太棒了。奥斯卡说：《办公室：美国
Workplace airing on PBS next month is a documentary following the employees of Scranton's own Dunder Mifflin Paper Company. Nellie goes on to say, in this series which will air starting in May, we get an in-depth look at many interesting local people. There's Kevin Malone, the Falstaffian accountant, Dwight Shrewt, the head salesman forever chasing a manager position he will never get. Andy Bernard, the rudderless trust fund child slash middle manager, who's in competence is emblematic of a declining American economy. A possible explanation for his lack of career focus is his surprising musical talent. Oh, Andy loves that.
职场》将于下月在PBS播出，这是一部纪录片，记录了斯克兰顿本土的邓德米弗林纸业公司的员工们。奈莉接着说，在这部将于五月开始播出的系列片中，我们得以深入了解许多有趣的当地人。有凯文·马龙，这位法尔斯塔夫式的会计；德怀特·舒鲁特，这位永远在追逐一个他永远得不到的管理职位的首席销售官；安迪·伯纳德，这位没有方向的信托基金之子兼中层管理者，他的无能象征着美国经济的衰落。他缺乏职业重心的可能原因是他令人惊讶的音乐才华。哦，安迪可太喜欢这个了。
He did. He's like, I'm going to need a copy of that. Aaron finishes with, though it mostly focuses on the daily realities of office life, a lurid subplot reveals the hypocrisy of a local public figure embroiled in a gay affair while preaching family values. Dun dun dun. Well, they say that this review was written by Josh McColliffe. He was a real writer at the Scranton Times.
他确实喜欢。他就像是，我得复印一份。艾伦最后念道，虽然它主要聚焦于办公室生活的日常现实，但一条耸人听闻的副线揭露了一位当地公众人物的虚伪，他在宣扬家庭价值观的同时，却卷入了一场同性恋情。咚咚咚。好吧，他们说这篇评论是乔希·麦考利夫写的。他是《斯克兰顿纪事报》的真实记者。
And Steve Burgess said we had a really good relationship with the Scrant Times and with Mary Potts at the Chamber of Commerce. And Steve said we had had some contact with Josh about the show over the years. So that's the name that they used for the article to make it more, I guess, authentic. Yeah. But he said, I don't think Josh knew about it. about it beforehand. Oh. Well, everyone in the bullpen isn't quite sure how to react to these reviews. Some people are offended, like Dwight. That one stung for him. Yeah. Andy at first was offended,
史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，我们与《斯克兰顿纪事报》以及商会的玛丽·波茨保持着非常良好的关系。史蒂夫说，这些年来我们一直就节目与乔希有一些接触。所以这就是他们为文章使用的名字，为了让它显得更，我猜，真实。对。但他说，我不认为乔希事先知道这件事。哦。好吧，办公区里的每个人都不太确定该如何对这些评论做出反应。有些人被冒犯了，比如德怀特。那条评论对他来说挺刺耳的。对。安迪起初被冒犯了，
but they became happy when they said he was talented. And then, of course, now Angela and Oscar are a little bit nervous. Stanley's going to finally arrive. He missed this whole thing. He's out of breath. He's mad at Dwight. And Dwight says, listen, I wish you would have just called me from downstairs because we have to go out on a sale now. And Stanley's like, hell no. I am not going anywhere. I'm not climbing those stairs again. Exactly. And then he demands from Pete.
但当他们说他很有才华时，他就开心了。然后，当然了，现在安吉拉和奥斯卡有点紧张。斯坦利终于要到了。他错过了整个过程。他气喘吁吁。他生德怀特的气。德怀特说，听着，我希望你刚才在楼下就给我打电话，因为我们现在得出去推销了。斯坦利却说，门儿都没有。我哪儿也不去。我再也不爬那些楼梯了。没错。然后他向皮特索要
He says, Pete, iced tea, three sugars, five creams. Pete says, your morning three by five coming up. Well, we had some folks write in about this, Jenna. What? Allie P from Rexburg, Idaho said, can you please try Stanley's three by fives? Are we going to try it? We are. Lady, I saw that fan question and I wanted to make that happen today and I couldn't make it happen and now you've made it happen.
他说，皮特，冰茶，三勺糖，五份奶精。皮特说，你那份标志性的“三五”茶马上来。詹娜，有些听众写信给我们谈到这个。什么？来自爱达荷州雷克斯堡的艾莉·P说，你们能尝尝斯坦利的“三五”茶吗？我们要尝吗？我们要尝。这位女士，我看到那个粉丝提问时，我今天就想把它变成现实，但我当时没能做到，而现在你让它成真了。
Well, don't get too excited. It's a lot of sugar and a lot of cream. But are you ready? I'm ready to try it. Okay, I'm going to go get it. Just a warning. It looks really gross. All right, Cassie. I'm sorry. All right. Sam's filming. Apologize in advance. Cheers. Cheers, Sam. Cheers. Ready? One, two. Three. Oh, God. That's horrible. Oh, God. God is horrible. There's so much sugar. So much sugar. Oh, God. I mean, what is that taste? I would like, Oh, I'm having a, I know, me too. I'm having a need to expel that. Nope. That's so bad. Oh, my God. That's so bad. Sorry, Stanley. Oh, my God. That's worse than. It's worse than I thought it was good. Do you, oh, God. Do you remember when I made the,
好吧，别太兴奋了。里面有很多糖和很多奶精。但你准备好了吗？我准备好尝尝了。好吧，我去拿。事先警告。它看起来真的很恶心。好吧，卡西。我很抱歉。好吧。萨姆在拍。提前道歉。干杯。干杯，萨姆。干杯。准备好了吗？一，二。三。哦，天哪。这太难喝了。哦，天哪。天哪，太难喝了。糖太多了。糖太多了。哦，天哪。我是说，这到底是什么味道？我想，哦，我有一种，我知道，我也是。我有一种想要把这东西吐出来的冲动。不。太糟糕了。哦，天哪。太糟糕了。对不起，斯坦利。哦，天哪。这比……这比我想象的还要好一点。不对，好个屁。你，哦，天哪。你还记得我做过那个吗？
The creamy orange juice? Yes, I do. Oh, that was better than this. Everyone's left. I'm the last person in the studio. They're dumping it down the drain. And I'm so grateful. That cleared the room.
那个奶油橙汁？是的，我记得。哦，那个比这个好喝多了。所有人都走了。我是录音室里最后一个人。他们在把这东西倒进下水道里。我太感激了。这把房间里的人全清空了。
That fully cleared the room. If you ever want to get rid of someone at a party, just give them that drink. How long have you been talking alone? I'm still. I just kept the podcast going. You guys all left. You just, it was like just,
这彻底把房间清空了。如果你想在派对上赶走任何人，只要给他们喝那杯东西就行。你一个人自言自语多久了？我还。我只是让播客继续录着。你们都走了。你们只是，就好像，
It was, I've never seen anything like it. It just emptied the whole room. I was like, well, I guess. No one even said goodbye. I didn't want to leave. You didn't say goodbye? I just took your drinking. I was like, well, I didn't want to leave our listeners.
这，我从来没见过这样的事。它直接把整个房间的人都清空了。我想，好吧，看来。甚至都没人说再见。我不想离开。你没说再见？我只是拿着你的饮料。我就想，好吧，我可不想抛弃我们的听众。
So I stayed. Oh, that was disgusting. Oh, I wish we hadn't done that so early in the podcast. I'm really sorry. I thought it'd be fun to try. Allie, I hope that was everything you hope for. It's disgusting. do not recommend.
所以我留了下来。哦，太恶心了。哦，真希望我们不要在播客一开始就喝那个。我真的很抱歉。我以为尝试一下会很有趣。艾莉，我希望这达到了你的全部期望。太恶心了。不推荐。
Well, moving on with a quiver in my voice, Pam is going to get off the phone with her mom, who is going to be babysitting the kids tonight. Nellie assumes this is because Jim and Pam are going to go have a, I guess, a hot night at a hotel or something. Pam just kind of smiles like, oh, sure. I just burped that stuff.
好吧，带着颤抖的声音继续，潘姆挂断了她妈妈的电话，她妈妈今晚要帮他们照看孩子。奈莉猜测这是因为吉姆和潘姆要去，我猜，去酒店过个火辣的二人世界什么的。潘姆只是笑了笑，一副“哦，当然”的样子。我刚才把那东西的味儿打嗝打出来了。
Lady, I'm so uncomfortable. The after-case is so uncomfortable. so hideous. It's just hideous, the aftertaste. I am struggling. Wow. That's a real kick in the nuts. It was one sip. I took one sip. That's it. That's it. I really think that if I'm ever in a film. And you feel you have to pretend to be nauseous. And I have to play nausea. Yeah. If I just took that one sip of that, I mean, I feel unsteady now. It's gross. Imagine if you had to take it. more than one step. Oh, God. And he drinks that every morning. That's his three by five. Sorry. Okay. Well, let's go outside because Pam and Nellie are now going to sit on a bench and they're
女士，我太难受了。这后劲太难受了。太可怕了。简直太可怕了，这后劲。我在苦苦挣扎。哇。这简直是当头一棒。这只是一小口。我就喝了一小口。就一口。就一口。我真的觉得，如果我以后拍电影。而你觉得自己必须假装恶心。而我必须扮演恶心的感觉。对。如果我刚才喝了那一小口那个东西，我是说，我现在都觉得站不稳了。太恶心了。想象一下如果你不得不喝。不止一口。哦，天哪。而他每天早上都喝那个。那是他的“三五”茶。抱歉。好吧，让我们去外面，因为潘姆和奈莉现在要坐在长椅上，她们要
going to have a real heart to heart. Yeah, Pam reveals that her and Jim are going to go to marriage counseling tonight. It's the first time they're doing this. Nellie says, oh, that's the only kind of counseling I've never had. Pam says, well, Jim is nervous, but she thinks it could help. Meanwhile, Jim has now gone over and approached Toby and asked him about his divorce. You guys, I want you to know, for my folks that love bloopers, there are some funny bloopers of this because Paul's reaction as Toby when Jim says, can I ask you about your divorce is really hilarious. And they broke a few times. I feel like I'm never going to be the same. I know.
进行一次走心的交谈。对，潘姆透露她和吉姆今晚要去进行婚姻咨询。这是他们第一次这么做。奈莉说，哦，那是唯一一种我从来没体验过的咨询。潘姆说，嗯，吉姆很紧张，但她觉得这会有帮助。与此同时，吉姆现在走过去找到了托比，向他打听他的离婚的事。伙计们，我想让你们知道，对于喜欢NG花絮的粉丝们来说，这里面有一些非常搞笑的NG花絮，因为当吉姆说“我能问问你离婚的事吗”时，保罗作为托比的反应真的太搞笑了。他们笑场了好几次。我觉得我再也回不到从前了。我知道。
I'm sorry. That drink is really, it really lingers, you guys. I mean, it really stays with you. you. It's like one of the worst things that's happened to me all year. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I have another thing to point out about this scene. What is it? When Toby goes, Kelly called it 2013 and then Clark enters and he's like, hey, hey, hey, get out of here, get out of here. And Clark says, my mistake. The scene ended there. But then Paul improvised this. Yes, it is your mistake. He's lingering, so annoying, I'm going to kill him. How can I help you? I'm here to help. So Paul improvised a little bit
我很抱歉。那杯饮料真的，后劲太大了，伙计们。我是说，它真的挥之不去。这简直是我今年遇到最糟糕的事情之一。我很抱歉。我很抱歉。我关于这个场景还有一件事要指出。是什么？当托比说“凯利称之为2013年”然后克拉克进来，他说“嘿，嘿，嘿，滚出去，滚出去”。克拉克说：“我的错。”场景到这里就结束了。但随后保罗即兴发挥了这句：是的，这就是你的错。他磨磨蹭蹭的，太烦人了，我要杀了。我能帮你吗？我是来帮忙的。所以保罗即兴发挥了一点
about, I'm going to kill him. Well, we got some mail. People thought maybe that that was an indication that Toby does have the potential to be the Scrant Strangler because he was so quick. So quick to turn on someone. Yes. All right. Next up, we're going to reveal Andy's obsession in this episode, which is getting an agent. Yeah, well, he has heard now in this review that people think he's talented musically, and he's like, this is my moment. I'm going to be famous. Yes, he calls the William Morris Agency, that's a real agency in Hollywood, and asks to speak with their best agent. You know, I remember when I first came to Hollywood, I tried Andy's method.
关于“我要杀了”。好吧，我们收到了一些邮件。人们觉得也许这表明托比确实有潜力成为斯克兰顿扼喉手，因为他反应太快了。翻脸比翻书还快。是的。好的，接下来，我们要揭晓安迪在本集中的执念，那就是找个经纪人。对，好吧，他现在在这篇评论中听说人们觉得他有音乐才华，他就觉得，这是我的时刻。我要出名了。是的，他打电话给威廉·莫里斯经纪公司，那是好莱坞一家真正的经纪公司，要求跟他们最好的经纪人通话。你知道，我记得我刚到好莱坞时，我试过安迪的方法。
I tried calling just like one of the top agencies, and the receptionist answered, and I went on like a long spiel about how I was new in town, but I was really dedicated. They were like, that's great. Yeah. Goodbye. I did the same thing with a really small agency. I didn't even shoot big. And I chatted up the receptionist. I heard they were great for comedic actors. I probably basically called the Carla Ferns, LA. And then I was like, I'll tell you what, I'll just drop off a headshot. And she was like, okay, bye. And she hung up. So then I went and I dropped off my head shot. Did anything happen? And I popped my head and I was like, hey, we spoke earlier on the phone. I was like, how are you? And she was like, just leave it there. Listen, that's the mix of like delusion and ambition you need to have when you're trying to make it
我试着打电话给某家顶级经纪公司，前台接了电话，然后我滔滔不绝地讲了一堆我是新人但我有多么敬业。他们就说，那挺好的。对。再见。我也对一家很小的经纪公司做过同样的事。我甚至都没敢想太大。我还跟前台闲聊。我听说他们对喜剧演员很好。我大概基本上是给洛杉矶的卡拉·费恩斯打电话了。然后我说，这么着吧，我直接送一份演员头像过来。结果她说，好吧，拜拜。然后她就把电话挂了。于是我真的去送了我的演员头像。发生什么了吗？我把头探进去说，嘿，我们刚才在电话里聊过。我说，你好吗？结果她说，放那儿就行了。听着，这就是你在这一行想闯出名堂时必须具备的那种妄想与野心的结合，真的。
in this business, truly. Absolutely. Because for every story that someone has where that didn't work, someone's got a story where it did. Yeah. You don't know which one you're going to be. Well, Robert Lipton, the state senator, has now pulled into the parking lot in his fancy car with his driver, Angela rushes to his car and gets back in and says, look, I am just so ready for our life to go back to normal. Ribbon cuttings, charity balls. And Robert's like, don't worry, I've scheduled a press conference for later today. We just need to face the camera together, a beloved public servant and his devoted wife. And Angela's like, fine, I will be the best damn wife. I'm correction, best darn wife. I'm sorry. I'm a better wife than that. She's going to stand by her man.
绝对的。因为对于每一个行不通的故事，总有人能讲出一个行得通的故事。对。你根本不知道自己会成为哪一种。好吧，州参议员罗伯特·利普顿现在坐着他的豪华轿车和司机驶入了停车场，安吉拉冲向他的车，坐了进去并说道：“看，我真的太渴望我们的生活回到正轨了。剪彩仪式、慈善舞会。”罗伯特则说：“别担心，我安排了今天晚上的记者招待会。我们只需要一起面对镜头，一个受人爱戴的公仆和他的贤妻。”安吉拉就说：“好吧，我会做该死的最棒的妻子。”更正，做最棒的贤妻。我很抱歉。我比那还要做个更好的妻子。她将坚定不移地支持她的男人。
I had an observation about this scene. What was that? Y'all look very dewy, very moist in this scene. Was it hot in the car? It was super hot and they had to turn the air off whenever we started rolling because you could hear it. And not only that, but I remember they had a little light that they stuck to the window on me. You know what I mean? It was like a little light that they'd put batteries in and suction cups and it was shining. into us in a hot car. So that do is sweat. Well, I asked Matt Sown about this, about this deweiness. And here is what he had to say. When we shoot in a car, we have to turn the air conditioning off so that we don't have any issues with sound and we can get clear dialogue. So the air conditioning could have been off. It was probably hot out in Panorama City when we did it. But I also believe that the windows were a little tinted in this town car, and we had to blast some light in to bring up our levels inside.
我对这个场景有个观察。什么观察？你们在这个场景里看起来都水灵灵的、非常湿润。车里很热吗？超级热，而且每次我们开始拍摄时，他们都必须把空调关掉，因为会有噪音。不仅如此，我还记得他们有个小灯，粘在我旁边的车窗上。你知道我的意思吗？就是一个装了电池、带有吸盘的小灯，它亮着，照着在炎热车里的我们。所以那个“水灵”其实是汗。好吧，我问过马特·索恩关于这种水灵感的问题。以下是他的回答。我们在车里拍摄时，必须关掉空调，这样才不会有声音问题，才能收录清晰的对话。所以空调当时可能是关的。我们拍的时候，全景城外面可能很热。但我也相信，这辆林肯轿车的车窗贴了一点膜，我们需要打一些强光进来，才能提高车内的亮度。
So that might have given them a stronger edge of a side light, but also might have made it even more hot in the car. That's exactly right. That's how I remember it. Angela, my curiosity about the temperature of the car was not satiated by this explanation. from that. You had to dig deeper about why we looked moist. I did. Okay. Where did that lead you? Well, first, it led me to the call sheet. Okay. Where I discovered that it was 64 degrees on that day that you were
所以这可能会让他们有一个更强的侧光边缘，但也可能会让车里更热。完全正确。我是这么记的。安吉拉，我对外面的温度并没有被这个解释满足。你得深入挖掘我们为什么看起来湿漉漉的。我确实查了。好的。那这把你带向了哪里？好吧，首先，它让我找到了通告单。好的。在那里我发现，你们拍摄的那天温度是64华氏度（约17.8摄氏度）。但阳光直射。好的。然后我找到一个在线汽车温度计算器。哦，天哪。它能根据外部温度和你在车里呆的时间，计算出停在烈日下的汽车内部温度。所以我计算了64度，烈日下45分钟，因为我想拍那个场景大概需要45分钟吧。是的。汽车温度计算器说，45分钟后，车内温度可能会高达101华氏度（约38.3摄氏度）。
shooting, but full sun. Okay. Then I found an online car temperature calculator. Oh, my word. It tells you the temperature inside a car sitting in the full sun based on the temperature outside, and how long you've been in the car. So I calculated 64 degrees full sun for 45 minutes because I thought probably takes about 45 minutes to shoot that scene. Yeah. The car temperature calculator said that after 45 minutes, it could be as high as 101 degrees in the car.
是的，没有空调呆在车里可不好。现在，我知道你们进进出出，他们会开足空调，所以可能从来没达到过101度。但汽车每10分钟就会升温20度。我们在工作巴士上就知道这一点。肯定有那么一次，你们在里面待了一会儿。而且你知道，如果什么东西升温了，我们知道，从潮热中我们知道，
Yeah, it's not good to be in a car without air. Now, I know that you guys were in and out and they would blast the air, so it probably never got up to 101 degrees. But cars heat up 20 degrees every 10 minutes. We know this on work bus. Surely there was a take where you guys were in there. And you know if something heats up, we know, we know from hot flashes,
如果某种东西以那种速度迅速升温，你就会变得非常湿润。所以即使当时是64度，10更不用提他穿着一身西装了。我穿着大衣。我们穿的是冬装。是的。
if something heats up kind of quickly like that, you get real moist. So even if it was 64 degrees and then 10 minutes later, it was 74 or 80s. you're going to be moist. Yeah. And not to mention he's in a full suit. I'm in a coat. We're dressed for winter. Yep.
因为斯克兰顿的冬天。是的。所以我们穿了那么多层衣服。但是，哇，了解这个比例真是太有趣了，因为这太危险了。这太危险了，即使在较低的温度下。是的。把宠物、熟睡的孩子或你自己留在没有任何通风的汽车里。无论多久，真的。
Because it's winter in Scranton. Yeah. So we had all those layers on. But wow, that is just such interesting to learn the ratio because it is so dangerous. It's so dangerous, even in cooler temperatures. Yes. To leave your pet or a sleeping child or yourself in a car without any ventilation. for any period of time, truly.
好吧，谢谢你做那项研究，女士。不客气。关于这个场景，我还有话要说。你有一个水灵/湿润的观察。我确实有。我有一张胡说八道的牌要打。是什么？是关于罗伯特·利普顿的。
Well, thank you for doing that research, lady. You are welcome. I have something to add about this scene. You had a Dewey-slash-moist observation. I did. I have a bull-h-card to play. What is it? It's about Robert Lipton.
他当时在车里就已经知道，他将在那场新闻发布会上说更多安吉拉不知道的事情。是的。而且他没有告诉她。她去参加这个新闻发布会，将完全被打个措手不及。是的。所以就在那里对罗伯特·利普顿胡说八道。
He knew in that car right at that moment that he was going to have a lot more to say at that press conference that Angela doesn't know about. Yeah. And he didn't tell her. She's going into this press conference and she's going to be completely blindsided. Yeah. So just calling bullshit on Robert Lipton right there.
哦，好吧。就这样。是的。好吧，他不是个好人。不。好吧，在这场戏的拍摄初稿中，删减片段中，安迪本来会走进达里尔的办公室，问达里尔运动员经纪公司是否可以代理他崭新的电视事业。哦，哇。是的。
Oh, okay. That's all. Yeah. Well, he's not a great person. No. Well, after this scene in the shooting draft, Annison deleted scenes, Andy would have gone into Daryl's office and asked Daryl if athlete could rep his new TV career. Oh, wow. Yeah.
他还谈到了简历上的特长。詹娜，我们谈论过我们是如何在简历的特长部分注水的。所以我想让你听听安迪说他的特长是什么。达里尔。
And he also talks about his special. skills on his resume. Jenna, we have talked about how we patted our special skills section of our resume. So I wanted you to hear what Andy says are his special skills. Daryl.
嘿。我想让你的公司分一杯安迪·伯纳德的羹。我想让运动员经纪公司代理我。我很抱歉，老兄。我们只代理运动员。这就是名称缩写的意思。所以你只是给那些已经拥有名气和财富的人带来更多的名气和财富？
Hey. I want to cut your firm in on the Andy Bernard business. I want to be repped by athlete. I'm sorry, man. We only represent athletes. That's what the aft stands for. So you just get more fame and wealth for people who already have it.
就是这个意思。好吧，这有点像瓮中捉鳖，你不觉得吗？你知道，我们明天有个董事会会议。我不能保证什么，但我很确信我不会提起这事的。但你不能保证。不能保证。我只想说这个。你爱怎么处理就怎么处理。
That's the idea. Well, it's a little like shooting fish in a barrel, don't you think? You know, we have a board meeting tomorrow. I can't make any promises, but I'm pretty sure I won't bring it up. But you can't make any promises. Can't make any promises. I'm just going to say this. You can do with it whatever you want.
当然。在我的演艺简历特长栏下。击剑和地滚球。这些都是体育运动。所以考虑一下吧。好的。不，我会记下的。酷。
Of course. On my acting resume under special skills. Fencing and tetherball. Those are sports. So just think about it. Okay. No, I'm going to write that. Cool.
我很喜欢那个。我太喜欢他把地滚球当作特长了。现在的孩子们还玩地滚球吗？有些公园有。我在这样那样的地儿见过。是吗？是吗？好吧。
I enjoyed that so much. I just loved that he put tetherball, a special skill. Do kids today even play tetherball? They're at a few parks. I've seen them here or there. Yeah? Yeah. Okay.
我小时候如果公园里有个地滚球，会觉得非常兴奋。我在地滚球比赛中总是被彻底击溃，因为我很矮。我很矮。是的。我曾经被地滚球砸到过脸。哦，不。我对地滚球没有美好的回忆。听起来确实没有。
That was like very exciting if the park had a tether ball when I was a kid. I was always absolutely destroyed in tetherball because I'm short. I'm short. Yeah. I once got hit in the face with a tether ball. Oh, no. I don't have good memories of tetherball. It doesn't sound like it.
好吧，现在安迪在等另一个经纪人的电话，德 Dwight 进来了。他在抱怨斯坦利。基本上，在这个场景中，安迪将授权德 Dwight 用一切可能的手段把斯坦利弄去参加这次销售拜访。是的。而且，你知道，德 Dwight 会有一段独白，说他过去五年一直压抑着自己的本能，因为他想当经理。但现在是时候让他释放这一点了，这真的很令人解脱。他现在要顺从自己的本能，这基本上包括弄一针牛用镇静剂，把斯坦利迷晕，好让他去开会。
Well, now Andy's on hold with another talent agent, and Dwight enters. He's complaining about Stanley. And basically, in this scene, Andy is going to give Dwight permission to get Stanley to this sales call by any means possible. Yeah. And, you know, Dwight's going to have a talking head that says for five years that he's held his instincts in check because he wanted to be manager. but now it's time for him to just let that go and it's really freeing. He's going to follow his instincts now, which basically involves getting a bull tranquilizer and drugging Stanley to get him to this meeting.
是的，德 Dwight 走进茶水间。克拉克正站在那里。克拉克在这场戏里有我最喜欢的台词之一。什么？当德 Dwight 说，斯坦利，不管用什么方法，你都得跟我去完成这笔生意。斯坦利走过去，然后克拉克说，嘿，在接下来不知什么事发生之前，你能让我离开这儿吗？是的，因为德 Dwight 拿着一把长得离谱的麻醉枪，他用小红镖一样的东西朝斯坦利射了三枪。然后斯坦利就瘫倒了。
Yeah, Dwight walks into the break room. Clark is standing there. Clark has one of my favorite lines in the episode in this scene. What? When Dwight says, Stanley, one way or another, you're going to come with me to make this sale. Stanley goes past and then Clark says, hey, can you just let me out of here before whatever comes next? Yeah, because Dwight's got this ridiculously long tranquilizer gun, and he shoots Stanley three times with little red dart things. And then Stanley collapses.
德 Dwight 对克拉克说，别担心，安迪批准了。好吧，正如你想象的那样，我们收到了很多关于这部分的信件。来自英国的大卫·H问：你们是如何营造出斯坦利被飞镖击中的幻觉的？来自加拿大的莉莉·B·G问：德 Dwight 射击斯坦利时，牛用镇静剂是用什么做的？史蒂夫·伯吉斯说那是视觉特效。我们并没有真的朝莱斯利·大卫·贝克开枪。我们拍摄了飞镖。
And Dwight says to Clark, don't worry, Andy approved this. Well, we got a lot of mail about this, as you can imagine. David H. from England said, how did you create the illusion of Stanley being shot with darts? And Lily B.G. from Canada said, what was used for the bull tranquilizers, when Dwight shoots Stanley. Well, Steve Burgess said it was visual effects. We did not actually shoot anything at Leslie David Baker. We filmed the dart.
我们拍摄了斯坦利。我们把飞镖粘在他的衣服上。然后在后期制作中，看起来就像飞镖射进他体内一样。哦，是的。全都是视觉特效。至于莱斯利被麻醉的时刻，马特·索恩说他们首先要弄清楚的是这把飞镖枪。他是这么说的。我们关于飞镖枪进行了很多讨论，要让它尽可能地看起来像一个良性武器。
We filmed Stanley. We attached the dart to his clothes. And then in post-production, it looks like the darts going into him. Oh, yeah. It was all visual effects. As far as the moment when Leslie is tranquilized, Matt Sone said the first thing they had to figure out was this dart gun. Here's what he said. We had a lot of conversations about the dart gun to make it feel as much of a
我们不希望德 Dwight 拿着一把真正的枪或步枪。所以我们凭空捏造了这个版本的飞镖枪，这就是我们最终想出的结果。是的，史蒂夫说我们试过几种不同的飞镖枪选项。电视台给了一条意见，他们不想让这看起来像个真正的武器。没错。于是菲尔·谢伊找到了我们用的这一款。它看起来有点像个发射飞镖的装置。它有那种非常长、有点细的管子。非常卡通化。是的，没错。马特·索恩还谈到莱斯利是如何完美演绎这一幕的。我觉得他表现得棒极了。我们听听马特是怎么说的。莱斯利非常精彩地瘫倒并落在一个我们准备好的垫子上。
benign weapon as possible. We didn't want a real gun or a rifle for Dwight to have. So we sort of concocted this version of what this dart gun was and that was what we came up with. Yeah, Steve said we went through a few different dart gun. options. The network had given a note that they didn't want this to look like an actual weapon. Right. And so Phil Shea found this one that we used. It looked kind of like a dart shooter. It had that really long, kind of like skinny. It was very cartoonish. Yeah, exactly. Matt Stone also talked about how Leslie really sold this moment. I thought he did fantastic. Let's hear what Matt said. Leslie did an amazing collapse and fall into a pad.
我们拍了好几次，但他真的很享受这个时刻，并且乐在其中。我觉得对于这一集来说，这对莱斯利来说是一个非常不同的体验。而且，这也给了我们一个有趣的时刻，看到雷恩和克拉克·杜克又有了像在西装仓库里那样的死党时刻。我认为克拉克在茶水间的反应，当这一切发生时，真是太棒了。嗯，我同意莱斯利在这场戏里表现出色。我是说，当他向前倒下时，你没看到他用手撑地什么的。我是说，这很难做到。这接下来将为德 Dwight 引发一个两难境地，那就是他如何把躺在茶水间地板上的斯坦利一路弄到车里去开会。所以也许我们应该描述一下他是怎么做到的。他首先是通过。
that we had set up. And we did it a couple times, but he really enjoyed the moment and had fun with it. I feel like for this episode, this was something that was very different for Leslie. And again, it gave us a fun moment to see Rain and Clark Duke have another buddy moment like they did in Suit Warehouse. I think that Clark's reaction in the break room, as all this is going down, was great. Well, I agree that Leslie was excellent in the scene. I mean, when he falls forward, you don't see him like brace himself with his hands or anything. I mean, that is hard to do. This is now going to set off a dilemma for Dwight, which is how does he get Stanley from the break room on the floor all the way down to the car and into a meeting. So maybe we should describe how he does that. He starts by. Somehow getting Clark to help him. Yeah, Clark witnessed this. He's in it now.
不知怎么让克拉克帮他。是的，克拉克目睹了这一切。他现在也卷进来了。是的。他们试图用手搬动他，但根本行不通。所以他们弄来了一把带轮子的办公室椅。我也想为莱斯利·大卫·贝克在轮椅上的演技点赞。哦，是的。所有的戏份。当他们拖着他并在他周围进行对话时，他必须保持不省人事的状态。我觉得他表现得棒极了。
Yeah. They're trying to move him by hand, and it is not working. So they get a roly office chair. I also want to give props to Leslie David Baker for his acting in the roly chair. Oh, yeah. All of it. He had to just be out of it while they're tugging him and having dialogue around him. I thought he did fantastic.
轮椅管用了，但是记住，电梯坏了。他们怎么把他弄下楼梯呢？是的。发生的事情是，我想德 Dwight 做了一个纸板坡道，现在他们需要把斯坦利裹在气泡膜里，还要给他头上绑个头盔。这看起来像是电影《蠢蛋搞怪秀》里的东西。真的挺像的。当他们讨论把他滑下楼梯的最佳方法时，斯坦利自己顺着楼梯滑下去了。
The roly chair works, but remember, the elevator's broken. how are they going to get him down the stairs? Yeah. What happens is I guess Dwight makes a cardboard ramp, and now they need to wrap Stanley in bubble wrap, and they're going to strap a helmet onto his head. This looks like something out of that movie Jackass. It really does. And while they're discussing the best way to kind of slide him down the stairs, Stanley slides down the stairs on his own.
意外滑下去的。他的头撞到了墙上，砸出了一个凹坑。最后他们把他弄到了停车场并塞进了车里。我们收到了雪花般飞来的粉丝邮件。我敢打赌。基本上，人们说，请给我们提供关于斯坦利特技的所有细节。莱斯利·大卫·贝克自己做了哪些特技，哪些是替身完成的？好吧，幸运的是，马特·索恩把这一切都分解了，他是这么说的。
By accident. And his head goes into the wall and leaves a divot. Eventually they get them down to the parking lot and into the car. We had a fan mail flurry. I bet. Basically, people said, please give us all the details on the Stanley stunts. What stunts did Leslie David Baker do versus the ones a stunt double did? Well, lucky for us, Matt Stone broke it all down, and here's what he had to say.
我们有些镜头用的是真正的斯坦利，但我们也用了一个特技演员来扮演斯坦利。就是那个我们在茶水间里把头撞向墙壁的特技演员。但当他们把他扔进椅子并推着他穿过大厅时，莱斯利都是亲自上阵的。说到楼梯间的滑行，我们讨论了如何拍摄的许多不同选项。我们有特技演员，所以我们讨论过使用特技演员来滑下来，但问题是这个滑行太危险了，因为不管是谁来做，他们的手臂都被气泡膜绑在身体两侧。所以我们最终认为，最安全的做法是做一个假人来滑下坡道并撞击墙壁，这也就是我们最终采取的做法，并且成功地隐藏了斯坦利的脸。
We have moments where we use the real Stanley, but we also had a stunt man playing Stanley. and it was the stuntman whose head we sort of ran into the wall in the break room. But Leslie did all of his own stuff when they were dropping him into the chair and pushing him down the hall. When it came to the stairwell slide, we had discussed many different options on how to do this. We had the stunt man, so we talked about using the stuntman. to slide down, but the problem was that it was too dangerous of a slide because whoever was going to do it, their arms were trapped in the bubble wrap by their side. So we ultimately figured it was the safest to build a dummy to slide down the ramp and hit the wall, which is ultimately what we did and
然后我们切到了事后莱斯利裹着头盔躺在墙上被撞出的洞旁边的画面。好了，把斯坦利弄进车里，莱斯利把昏迷不醒的状态演得太棒了。而且，你知道，这对克拉克和雷恩来说都是一个挑战，因为莱斯利没有什么控制力，因为他裹着气泡膜，手臂夹在身体两侧。他们不得不连拉带拽地试图把他弄进车里。我们在很多剪辑中也处理了这一点，这把这个时刻卖力地呈现出来了。我不得不说我觉得它天衣无缝。是的。我是说，那是一个假人、一个特技替身和莱斯利。
managed to hide Stanley's face. And then we have the cutaway after the fact of Leslie wrapped up in the helmet by the hole that we punched in the wall. Now, getting Stanley into the car, Leslie played great at being passed out. And, you know, it was a challenge for both Clark and Rain because Leslie didn't have a lot of control because he was in the bubble wrap and his arms were by his side. And they had to sort of maneuver him around and attempt to get him in, to the car. We did that in a lot of edits as well, which kind of sold the moment. I have to say I thought it was seamless. Yeah. I mean, it was a dummy, a stunt double, and Leslie.
他们把这些组合得非常棒。我根本看不出来。是的。史蒂夫说莱斯利的特技替身是巴迪·索斯特。布雷特·琼斯是我们这一集的特技统筹。我对马特谈到的那个斯坦利假人有点好奇。所以我联系了史蒂夫·伯吉斯，我问，莱斯利是不是必须做那种制作脸模的事情，或者，你知道的，你以前见过那种，对吧？史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，菲尔实际上用了一个他已经现有的假人。既然它裹在气泡膜里还戴着头盔，效果还挺好的。它蒙混过关了。
They did a great job putting that together. And I could never tell. Yeah. Steve said Leslie's stunt double was Buddy Sawstand. Brett Jones was our stunt coordinator for this episode. I got a little curious about the Stanley dummy that Matt talked about. So I reached out to Steve Burgess, I was like, did Leslie have to do that thing where you get like a face cast made or, you know, you've seen that before, right? Steve Burgess said Phil actually used a dummy that he already had. And since it was wrapped up in bubble wrap and wearing a helmet, it kind of worked. It sold it.
所以，不，莱斯利不必经历12小时的面部塑形。很明显，所有看到脸的镜头都是莱斯利，滑下楼梯的是假人，但当我们切回楼梯底部的假人时，那又是莱斯利了。真是太神奇了。关于这个序列，安吉拉，我们确实收到了另一个粉丝的问题，来自洛杉矶的詹娜·F。她经常来信。是的。她注意到雷恩顺着纸板滑下来，真的。
So no, Leslie did not have to sit through some 12-hour molding of his face. obviously all the shots where we see a face are Leslie, the slide down the stairs is the dummy, but then when we cut back to the dummy at the end of the stairs, that was Leslie again. It was just amazing. We did get another fan question about this sequence, Angela, from Jenna F. in Los Angeles. She writes in a lot. Yeah. She noticed that rain slid down the cardboard and really.
真的觉得这可能是雷恩临时起意做的，把大家都吓坏了。我问了马特·索恩关于这件事的情况，他是这么说的。你就是那个来自洛杉矶的詹娜·F吗？这真是个巧合。雷恩真的很想从楼梯上滑下来，我觉得制作组告诉过他不要这么做，但他还是做了。这有点融入了场景中。非常搞笑。
really felt like this was something Rain might have done on the fly that made everyone freak out. I asked Matt Sone about it and here's what he said. Are you the Jenna F in Los Angeles? It's a coincidence. Rain really wanted to slide down the stairs and I feel like production told him not to, but he did it anyway. And it was sort of within the scene. It was very funny.
但是，再次强调，制作组希望保证演员的安全。而且那是一个很长的滑梯。雷恩滑了。我想他挺享受的。我想他可能滑了两次。但我不敢确定，那也可能是我们的最后一条。因为我觉得我们讨论过他滑下去的事，而且有人告诉过他不要滑。
But again, production wants to keep the actors safe. And it was a long slide. Rain did the slide. I think he enjoyed it. I think he did it maybe twice. But I'm not sure it could have also been our last take. Because I feel like we had discussed him sliding down and he was told not to.
但他还是做了。而且这个镜头被剪进去了。非常搞笑，而且感觉很真实。是的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯也证实了雷恩是临时起意做的。好吧，我当时在停车场那边跟参议员拍戏呢。而且我清楚地记得我们的剧组人员顺着它滑下去。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，这就是为什么雷恩这么做时他们并没有那么担心，因为剧组人员一整天都在这么玩。
But he did it anyway. And it made the cut. And it was very funny and felt realistic. Yeah. Steve Burgess also confirmed that Rain did. it on the fly. Well, I was filming over on that side, you know, with the senator in the parking lot. And I distinctly remember our crew guys sliding down it. Steve Burr just said that that was why they weren't that concerned when Rain did it because the crew had been doing it all day.
是的。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，我们将为吉姆和帕姆进行真正的治疗。是的，回来后就是夫妻治疗。嗯哼。好了，我们回来了。我想先说一句，那种恶心的饮料让我们难受，现在我终于感觉又正常了。我知道我们上周说过。我爱我们的空间。今天我从车里走过来的时候，我遇到了一件事，非常迷人。这让我更加热爱我们的新工作室了。是什么事？好吧。所以，你知道，我们位于一个有点旅游区的地方。确实是。街上有一个家庭，他们在看手机。在我看来他们像游客。
Yep. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're going to get some real therapy session for Jim and Pam. Yeah, couples therapy when we're back. Mm-hmm. Right, we're back. I'd like to start by saying, I finally feel normal again from that from the nasty drink that we drink. And I know we said it last week. I love our space. When I was coming in today from the car, I had an encounter and it was so charming. And it just made me love our new studio even more. What was it? Okay. So, you know, we're located in a little bit of a touristy area. We are. And there was a family on the street and they were looking at their phone. And they look like tourists to me.
没错。我想，哦，我要去跟他们打个招呼。我要问他们需不需要指路。因为他们看起来有点迷路。有点迷路。嗯哼。所以我说，嘿，你们在旅行吗？你们是游客吗？
Right. And I thought, oh, I'm going to say hi to them. I'm going to ask them if they need directions. Because they looked a little lost. A little bit. Mm-hmm. So I said, hey, are you traveling? Are you tourists?
他们看了我一眼。他们停顿了一下。然后他们解释说他们是法国人，不太会说英语。我说，哦。Bonjour？我说，“bonjour”。你的法语突然像在那个市场上那样恢复了吗？对。
And they looked at me for a second. They kind of paused. And then they explained that they were French, that they didn't really speak English. And I said, oh. Bonjour? I said, bonjour. Did all of a sudden your French come back to you like it did in that market? Right.
我希望如此，我说，我英语说得一点点。然后我说，“Trey en puerto de France”。法语说得非常少。那个人说，“a petite de Franca”。我说，是的，“petite de Franca”。不是“trie en per”。总之，我们度过了一个时刻。他们在找星光大道。我能够用“a gauche”（向左）和“a d'Aduat”（向右）为他们指路。我当时为自己感到非常骄傲。然后我做了一件疯狂的事，女士，这很疯狂吗？我说，你们在法国看《办公室》吗？你才没有呢。我真的说了。这可不像你的风格。你可是那种低调行事的人。我知道，但我想，如果你是个游客，从法国来到这里，正步行前往好莱坞星光大道，然后你偶遇了一位男演员或女演员，难道你不想跟那个人合个影吗？也许吧。后来呢？他们不看《办公室》，似乎从来没听说过。他们以为你在办公室工作。所以，我没开玩笑。我一不做二不休，当场谷歌了自己，把手机拿给他们看。詹娜·费舍尔。我说，这就是我。你现在是谁？
I was hoping, and I said, I speak a little English. And then I said, Trey en puerto de France. Very little French. And the man said, a petite de Franca. And I said, yes, petite de Franca. Not trie en per. But anyway, we had a moment. They were looking for the walk of fame. I was able to give them directions using a gauche and a d'Aduat. I was very proud of myself. And then I did a crazy. thing, lady, is this crazy? I said, do you all watch the office in France? You did not. I did. This is not like you. You are Miss Fly under the radar. I know, but I'm like, if you're a tourist and you've come from France and you're walking to the Hollywood Walk of Fame and you've run into an actor or an
他们说，詹娜·费舍尔。我说，对，那就是我。我是詹娜·费舍尔。然后他们变得非常兴奋，两个女孩，她们看起来有点像十几岁的少女。她们想要一张合影，于是我们拍了一张。我能看出当他们走开时，他们像是在心里默默记下：我们遇到了詹娜·费舍尔。
actress, don't you want a picture with that person? Maybe so. What happened? They don't watch the office, seemed to have never heard of it. They think you work in an office. So, I kid you not. I doubled down and I googled myself and I showed my phone to them. Jenna Fisher. I said, this is me. Who are you right now?
我们不知道她是谁。她可能从未看过她的电视节目。著名的前台接待员？我们不知道。但那就是我在进门路上的小偶遇。太迷人了。我不知道。我真不敢相信你这么做了。
And they said, Jenna Fisher. And I said, yes, that's me. I'm Jenna Fisher. And then they got all excited and the two girls, they were like kind of teen girls. They wanted a picture and we took a picture. And I could tell as they were walking away that they were like, like making a note to themselves. We've met Jenna Fisher.
好吧，我最喜欢做的事情之一是，当我们开车去某个地方时，那些旅游巴士之一，那些露天的游客面包车从旁边开过，你们刚好在红灯前并排停着。我总是喜欢摇下车窗说，嘿，大家好，欢迎来到洛杉矶。好吧，我喜欢做的是，当我度假时，如果我看到一对情侣也在度假，他们正试图做情侣们常做的那种事——在某处美景前自拍，但没有人帮他们拍，而他们又可能不想麻烦别人。我会走到那对情侣或家庭面前说，你们想要一张合影吗？我来帮你们拍。这就是我最喜欢做的事。有时候人们认出我，有时候认不出来。但我从来不说任何话。你不会掏出手机谷歌自己并解释你是谁吗？我不会。但当那种时刻发生时总是很有趣。我只记得第一次和家人还有姐姐去洛杉矶的时候。我想我在这个家庭里看到了自己的影子。没错。可爱的一家。我当时多么渴望能偶遇某位电影和电视界的人士啊。如果朱莉娅·罗伯茨说，“你们需要指路吗？”。你知道我们遇到了谁。黛安·基顿。你和你的家人。
We don't know who she is. She might never seen her TV show. Famous receptionist? We don't know. But that was my little encounter on the way in. That's so charming. I don't know. I can't believe you did.
我们在街上跟她擦肩而过，我妈妈至今深信黛安·基顿是在赞美她的帽子。家族故事。这成了传奇。是的，还记得黛安·基顿看到我的帽子时回头多看了一眼吗？好吧，我们该去哪？这场非常激烈的对话正在进行中，发生在帕姆和内莉以及吉姆和托比之间。镜头在两边切来切去。他们也确实分享了很多事情。我当时就想，哇，这场治疗，会是一场硬仗。是的，我是说，
Well, one of my favorite things to do is when we're driving somewhere and one of those like tour buses, those like open air vans of tourists drive by and you're kind of at a stoplight together. I was like to roll down my window and be like, hey, everybody, welcome to L.A. Well, what I like to do is when I'm on vacation and I see a couple and they're also on vacation and they're trying to do that thing that couples do where you take a selfie in front of some beautiful thing, but you don't have someone to take it for you and you don't want to ask someone, maybe. I go up to that couple or family and I say, do you guys want a group picture? I'll take it for you. And that's my favorite thing to do. And sometimes people recognize me and sometimes they
帕姆有点像是在说，好吧，吉姆没有跟我商量就做了这个，没有跟我商量就做了那个，那他在什么情况下才会停止因为擅自为我们的生活做重大决定而受到嘉奖呢？然后吉姆说，你知道吗，如果不是我引领这些生活中的重要时刻，帕姆现在还嫁给罗伊呢。有人对吉姆的这句话有很大的意见。哦。来自英国的泰尼莎·T·T。泰尼莎，让我们听听她的声音。泰尼莎说，我有小小的抱怨，我一直在等这一集，因为每当吉姆暗示如果他不擅自做决定，帕姆就会嫁给罗伊时，我都气得要死。我需要分享这一直以来让我多么沮丧。泰尼莎接着说，帕姆选择和罗伊分手。吉姆当时已经离开斯克兰顿去斯坦福分公司工作了。帕姆之所以解除
don't. But I don't ever say anything. You don't get out your phone and Google yourself and explain who you are. I don't. But it's always fun when that moment happens. I just remember coming to L.A. for the first time with my family and my sister. And I think I just saw myself in this family. Right. Sweet family. And how much I just wanted to run into some person from film and television. If Julia Roberts had been like, do you need help with directions? Well, you know who we ran into. Diane Keaton. You and your family.
与罗伊的婚约，是因为她意识到那不是她想要的。然后她租了新公寓。她开始上艺术课。她的艺术作品入选了艺术展。她在《海滩游戏》那一集里走了煤炭步行，还有全剧中的更多角色成长，所有这些都是在没有吉姆参与的情况下完成的，而且当时吉姆甚至都不对她友好了。所以我认为吉姆说帕姆会嫁给罗伊，完全无视了帕姆所有的成就，这感觉很不符合吉姆会说的话。我挺喜欢的。我喜欢那个。太棒了。我喜欢这个观察。好吧，最终，吉姆对托比说，你知道，如果帕姆能再坚持一会儿，这对我们家来说将是一个巨大的转机。然后托比说，那“一会儿”到底是什么意思？
We passed her on the street and my mom is convinced to this day that Diane Keaton admired her hat. Family story. It's legend. Yeah, remember that time Diane Keaton did a double take when she saw my hat. Well, where should we go? This very intense conversation is how to. happening between Pam and Nellie and Jim and Toby. We're cutting back and forth. They're really sharing a lot of stuff too. I'm just like, wow, this therapy session is, it's going to be a big one. Yeah, I mean,
因为，你知道，对于帕姆来说，要她答应一件让她不开心的事情，她需要知道，到底有没有一个截止日期？吉姆说，嗯，这是一个相当不可能回答的问题。所以在这个剧集的剧本围读之后，当我们进行笔记总结环节时，格雷格解释了他对这些场景的目标。他说他希望这些场景的拍摄和剪辑方式能让吉姆和帕姆看起来像是在互相交谈。既然我们无法真正让摄像机进入他们的夫妻咨询室，这就是我们能够看到他们可能会说些什么的版本。没错，这是对正在发生的事情的一窥。格雷格说，托比认真对待这件事以及内莉认真对待这件事也非常重要。约翰·卡拉辛斯基还给出了意见，认为托比和内莉应该在某些方面挑战我们。
Pam kind of says, okay, Jim did this without asking me, this without asking me, at what point does he stop getting rewarded for making big life decisions without me? And then Jim says, you know what, if I didn't usher in these life moments, Pam would still be married to Roy. There's someone who has a real issue with that statement from Jim. Oh. And it is Tenisha T. Tee from the UK. Tenisha, let's hear it. Tenisha says, I have a small rant and I've been waiting to get to this episode because it has always made me so mad when Jim suggests that if he didn't do things without telling Pam, she'd be married to Roy. I need to share how upset this has always made me. Tenisha goes on to say, Pam chose to break up with Roy. Jim had already left Scranton to work at the Stanford branch. Pam broke off
因为最初来自内莉和托比的那些挑战，在桌上剧本里是没有的。所以那些是后来加进去的。我觉得这是一个非常好的改动。你知道，约翰曾提议托比应该说类似这样的话：“你觉得这让帕姆怎么想？”也许内莉应该说：“我不明白，为什么不直接去，直接去呢”，这样他们某种程度上就被迫去面对那些阻止他们度过这段艰难时期的阻碍。我真的很喜欢这一点。我很喜欢他们这段关系中的这个节奏。我也是。我确实在拍摄初稿中读到，上面写着内莉太投入了，当帕姆在说所有这些她想要改变的事情时，内莉在帕姆的讲话中迷失了自我，然后直接说：“我会改变的，帕姆。”然后她又反应过来，哦，等等。是的，现在亚伦要把大家叫过来，在她的电脑上观看参议员利普顿的新闻发布会。安吉拉出现在电视上，她看起来真的很棒。他们说她看起来像个电影明星。这当然把安迪气坏了，因为他认为安吉拉正在迎来她本该由他来享受的宏大电视高光时刻。
the engagement with Roy because she realized it wasn't what she wanted. Then she got a new apartment. She started art classes. Her art was included in an art exhibition. She did the Colwalk in the Beach Games episode and so much more character growth throughout the series, all of which she did without Jim, all at a time when Jim wasn't even being friendly with her anymore. So I just think that Jim saying that Pam would be married to Roy completely disregards all
但这场新闻发布会可不会按安吉拉希望的那样发展。不，一点也不。罗伯特一开头就说，我首先想说的是，关于我的私生活有一些谣言，我想一劳永逸地解决它们，正如我饱受折磨的妻子所能证明的那样，我是同性恋。人群惊讶地反应。一个记者说，参议员，你一直都是同性恋，还是你妻子把你变成同性恋的？接着下一个记者说，这是问参议员的胡子（指形婚妻子）的问题。皮特心疼安吉拉。菲利斯有点在享受这个时刻。她就像是，没错，可怜的安吉拉。参议员还没说完。他要再接再厉，说道，我曾经相信同性恋者可以多少有点直（异性恋）。直到我和安吉拉结婚，我才意识到女性身体让我觉得多么毫无魅力。梅雷迪思说，噢，听到这个总是很伤人。罗伯特接下来要感谢奥斯卡。哦，奥斯卡亮了。他太高兴了。就在那时，办公区的人发现奥斯卡也和参议员有染。嗯哼。
of Pam's accomplishments, and it felt like a very un-jim thing for him to have said. I liked it. I liked that. That is fantastic. I love that observation. Well, ultimately, Jim tells Toby, you know, if Pam could just hold on a little bit longer, this would be huge for our family. And then Toby says, well, what does a little while mean?
我得告诉你，布莱恩饰演的凯文在这个时刻的表现绝对惊艳，我觉得我们应该听听。是的，我从头到尾都知道。我保守了这个秘密。我把这个秘密保守得太好了。你不知道，你不知道，你丫的根本不知道，但我知道。是的，我们做到了。你做到了，凯文。是的。
Because, you know, for Pam to sign on to something that makes her unhappy, she's going to need to know, is there an end date? And Jim says, well, that's a pretty impossible question. So after the table read of this episode, when we were doing our kind of notes session, Greg explained his goal for these scenes. He said that he wanted them to be shot and cut in such a way that it would look like Jim and Pam were talking to each other. Since we couldn't actually have cameras go into their couples counseling, this was our version of being able to see what they might say there. Right, a sneak peek into what's going on. Greg said it was also really important that Toby take this seriously and that Nellie take it seriously. And John Krasinski also gave the note that Toby and Nellie should challenge us in some way.
哦，我做到了。哦，我做到了。这是我最喜欢的慢热笑话之一。他已经知道这么久了。这么久。而且他做到了。他做到了。他把那个秘密保守得太好了。
Because originally those kind of challenges from Nellie and Toby, they weren't in the table draft. So those got added. I thought that was a really good thing. You know, John had pitched that Toby should say something like, how do you think this makes Pam feel? And maybe Nellie should say, I don't understand. NYU don't just go, just go, so that they're kind of being forced to address these things that are stopping them from getting through this rough patch. And I really liked this. I liked this beat for their relationship. I did too. I did read in the shooting draft that it said Nellie is so invested
好吧，这个新闻发布会场景本来要长得多。罗伯特接着说，奥斯卡才是真正让他睁开眼睛看到真爱韦斯利的人。是的，他令人惊叹的参谋长，他深爱的人。是的，他们接吻了。还有更多内容。在删减片段里。安吉拉仍然试图挽救她的婚姻，但参议员为她准备了更多惊喜。你得听听这个。
that when Pam is saying all these things that she wants to change, Nellie loses herself in Pam's speech and then just says, I will change, Pam. And then she's like, oh, wait. Yeah. Well, now Aaron is going to call everyone over to watch Senator Lipton's press conference on her computer. Angela's on the TV, and she looks real good. They say she looks like a movie star. This, of course, pisses Andy off because he thinks Angela's having her big TV moment that he should be having.
参议员利普顿，这会对你的家庭安排产生什么影响？你和利普顿太太还会继续住在一起吗？当然。如你所知，罗伯特和我有一个年幼的孩子。我将搬去和韦斯利同住。什么？我们需要了解我们作为伴侣的意义。罗伯特，我们从来没讨论过这个。你会借此机会推动共和党在同性婚姻立场上的变革吗？不，我只是要转投民主党。什么？安吉拉最后感到无比尴尬，我记得在这个场景结束时跟马特·索恩谈过，因为他们让我一直站在那里看完整场戏，而参议员则一个接一个地抛出重磅炸弹。我说，马特，她总得有个崩溃点吧。我是说，她不会就这么一直站在那里的。所以在最后，当他说要转投民主党时，马特说，做你觉得安吉拉在这种时刻会做的事。
But this press conference is not going to go the way. Angela had hoped. No, not at all. Robert starts off by saying, I would just like to start by saying there have been some rumors about my personal life that I would like to settle once and for all, as my long-suffering wife can attest, I am gay. The crowd reacts surprised. And a reporter says, Senator, were you always gay or did your wife turn you gay? And then the next reporter says, question for the Senator's beard. Pete's like poor Angela. Phyllis is sort of a enjoying this moment. She's like, yeah, poor Angela. The senator is not done. He's going to double down and say, I once believed that a gay person could be somewhat straight. It wasn't until my marriage to Angela that I realized how charmless I find the female body. Meredith says, oof, always hurts to hear that one. Robert is then going to go on to thank Oscar. Oh, Oscar lights up. He's so delighted. And that's when the bullpen finds out that Oscar was also seeing the senator. Mm-hmm.
好的。我推倒了麦克风架，气冲冲地离开了舞台。那是最后一根稻草。是的。所有这些别的事情。没错。但唯独不是那个。好吧，各位，韦斯利·西尔弗由弗雷德·克罗斯饰演。他是一位喜剧演员、即兴喜剧演员，也是“第二城”喜剧团的毕业生。我们已经听说他一段时间了。但是天哪，这真是一个重磅炸弹。
Let me tell you, Brian's performance as Kevin in this moment is absolutely amazing, and I think we should hear it. Yes, and I knew it the whole time. I kept the secret. I kept the secret so good. You didn't know, you didn't know, you didn't freaking know, but I knew. Yes, we did it. You did it, Kevin. Yes.
是的。对安吉拉和奥斯卡的这种背叛将引发接下来几集里一些非常有趣的事情。是的，因为他们过去有着共同的爱，但现在他们将有一个共同的敌人。接下来是一个如此搞笑的场景。安迪找到了他希望成为的新经纪人。那是卡拉·费恩。拍摄初稿中是这样描述这个场景的。上面写着，安迪坐在一个非常狭窄、简陋的候诊室里，
Oh, I did it. Oh, I did it. That is one of my best, like, slow play jokes. He has known for so long. So long. And he did it. He did it. He kept that secret so good.
几把椅子，一个看起来很破旧的饮水机，还有一株塑料植物。一位妈妈在看杂志，她满脸雀斑、顶着红头发、穿着夹克打着领带的儿子在玩她的手机。安迪看着候诊室的对面，一个衣着干净利落的男人坐在那里。旁边是一只活狗，狗背上有一只活猫，猫背上有一只活老鼠。是的。安迪会认出这个人并说，你是个演员吗？他说，我不是演员，但我有个表演。是狗、猫、鼠。安迪说，训练它们做那个很难吗？那个人说，嗯，我经历过很多老鼠。我们收到了来自田纳西州查塔努加市艾布琳·R的粉丝提问。
Well, this press conference scene was much longer. Robert's going to go on to say that Oscar is who really opened up his eyes to his true love, Wesley. Yes, his amazing chief of staff who he is in love with. Yes, and they kiss. There was even more. It's in the deleted scenes. Angela is still going to try to salvage her marriage, but the senator has more surprises in store for her. You got to hear this.
她说，哦，天哪，那是带着狗、猫、老鼠在选角办公室里的保罗·菲格吗？他太搞笑了。他的独白台词交付太惊艳了。这是怎么来的？是的，艾布琳，这就是保罗·菲格。格雷格想让保罗扮演这个角色。他太、太搞笑了。他太搞笑了。
Senator Lipton, what effect will this have on your family arrangement? Will you and Mrs. Lipton continue living together? Of course. As you know, Robert and I have a young child. I'll be moving in with Wesley. What? We need to know who we are as a couple. Robert, we never discussed this. Will you take this opportunity to promote change in the Republican Party
我想我们可以听听他的独白，然后我再分享糖果袋的备选台词。我太喜欢了。训练它们做那个很难吗？你经历过很多老鼠。其实这是个意外，就像这种事情往往会发生的那样。我当时在放我的猫，不小心把它放在了我的狗身上，起初我对气死自己了。然后我想，等等，等等一下。所以那段独白其实是糖果袋备选台词。是的。他本来会接着说，我的前妻对每个人说老鼠是她的主意，但我对此一点印象都没有。不管怎样，我自己也会想到的。
with respect to their stance on gay marriage? No, I'll just be switching to the Democratic Party. What? Angela is so mortified at the end, and I remember talking to Matt Sone at the end of the scene because they had me just standing there through the whole thing as the senator just keeps dropping one bomb after another. And I said, Matt, she's got to have a breaking point at some point. Like, she wouldn't just keep standing there. So at the end, when he says he's going to switch to the Democratic Party, Matt said, do whatever you think Angela would do in this moment.
这里还有其他的独白选项。我演过生日派对，退休派对。我曾经做过一家鞋店的开业活动。我至今仍试图仅仅靠在CVS后面的停车场表演所赚的钱生活。在此之外的一切都是额外的收获，因为你不知道这一切什么时候会消失。这里还有另一个。我想我现实中的梦想是表演一个马、狗、猫、老鼠，四个叠成一列，你知道吗？然后有时候，我知道这听起来怎么样，但我想象用一块奶酪放在老鼠的帽子的那种方式表演所有这四个动物。你不会觉得奶酪是最难的部分，但它们所有人都爱奶酪。好吧，安迪确实问了，老鼠头上会放东西吗？他说，是的，一顶小帽子。
Okay. I shoved the microphone stand over and I stormed off the stage. That was the last straw. Yeah. All this other stuff. Right. But not that. Not that. Well, you guys, Wesley Silver was played by Fred Cross. He's a comedian and improv actor and graduate of the Second City. And we've heard about him for a while now. But boy, this was a shocker.
然后安迪问老鼠有没有名字，那个人说给老鼠起名字是没有意义的。没错。然后保罗·菲格即兴发挥了这句台词。它们有点像炮灰，你知道的？你不是那种善待动物组织的人吧？然后猫从狗身上跳下来，他说，哦，太好了。我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州凯伦·T的粉丝提问，她说，我需要了解关于老鼠、猫和狗的一切。怎么做到的？
Yeah. All of this betrayal of both Angela and Oscar is going to lead to some pretty fun stuff coming up in these next few episodes. Yes, because they used to have a common love, but now they're going to have a common enemy. Up next is such a hilarious scene. Andy has found what he hopes to be his new agent. It's Carla Fern. This is how this scene is described in the shooting draft. It says, Andy sits in a very narrow, bare-bones waiting room,
来自加拿大的莉莉·B说，这些动物是从鲍勃·邓恩动物租赁公司租来的吗？它们本来就会做那个吗？还是专门为这一集训练的？好吧，各位，我要告诉你们，我深入研究了这个。我查清了关于他们如何堆叠这些动物的一切。我个人非常喜欢动物堆叠。是的，我觉得你应该分享一下这个，比如我有多喜欢当动物被打扮成其他动物的时候。比如如果你把你的狗打扮成一只小兔子。
some chairs, a dingy-looking water cooler, and a very plastic plant. A mom reads a magazine as her freckled-faced red-head son, dressed in a jacket and tie, plays with her phone. Andy looks across the waiting room where a clean-cut man sits. next to a live dog with a live cat on top, and the cat has an alive mouse on top of it. Yes. Andy is going to spot this man and say, are you an actor? And he says, I'm not an actor, but I have an act. It's dog cat mouse. Andy says, is it hard to train them to do that? And the man says, well, I've gone through a lot of mice. We got a fan question from Abilene R in Chattanooga, Tennessee.
是的。就像万圣节那样，我喜欢那样。我喜欢动物堆叠在其他动物身上的画作。奇怪的是，我有一幅婴儿时期的画，上面画着动物彼此堆叠。我知道。我和我的朋友亚历克斯，我们都喜欢动物堆叠。我们互相发送不同动物堆叠的照片。你知道吗？我喜欢任何猫趴在山羊身上或者狗趴在牛身上的视频。我不知道，我就是喜欢它们骑在彼此身上。我不知道。你见过的最喜欢的动物堆叠是什么？
who said, oh my God, is that Paul Figue at the casting office with the dog, cat, and mouse? He's so funny. His talking head delivery was amazing. How did this come about? Yes, Abilene, this was Paul Figue. Greg wanted Paul to play this role. And he is so, so funny. He's so funny.
谁说，天哪，那是保罗·费格带着狗、猫和老鼠在选角办公室吗？他太搞笑了。他面对镜头的访谈表现太惊艳了。这是怎么回事？是的，阿比林，这就是保罗·费格。格雷格希望保罗来演这个角色。他真的太好笑了，太好笑了。
I thought we could hear his talking head, and then I would share the candy bag alts. I love it. Is it hard to train them to? do that? You go through a lot of mice. It started by accident, actually, as these things tend to do. I was setting it out my cat and I accidentally put her on top of my dog and I was like so mad at myself at first. And I was like, wait, wait a second. So that talking head was actually the candy bag alt. Yes. And he would have gone on to say, my ex-wife tells everyone the mouse was her idea, but I don't have any recollection of that. Anyway, I would have thought of it.
我以为我们可以听到他的访谈，然后我会分享糖果袋的备选片段。我太喜欢了。训练它们做那个很难吗？你会用掉很多老鼠。其实这最初是个意外，事情往往就是这样。我当时正放下我的猫，不小心把它放在了我的狗背上，一开始我还生自己的气。然后我想，等等，等一下。所以那个访谈实际上是糖果袋的备选。是的。他本会接着说，我前妻到处跟人说老鼠是她的主意，但我对此一点印象都没有。总之，我自己也能想到。
it myself. And here were the other talking head options. I've done birthdays, retirement parties. I did a shoe store opening once. I still try to live off just the money I get from performing in parking lots behind CVS. And then everything beyond that is bonus, because you don't know when this could all go away. Here's another one. I guess my realistic dream is to do a horse, dog, cat, mouse, all four in a column, you know? And then sometimes, and I know how this is, and I know how this sounds, but I imagine doing all four of those with like a piece of cheese on top of the mouse's hat. You wouldn't think the cheese is the hardest part, but all of them love cheese. Well, Andy does ask, does anything go on top of the mouse? And he says, yes, a little hat.
而且这里还有其他的访谈选项。我办过生日派对、退休派对。我曾经做过一家鞋店的开业活动。我至今仍试图靠在CVS后面的停车场表演赚来的钱过活。除此之外的一切都是额外的奖励，因为你不知道这一切什么时候会消失。这里还有另一个。我想我现实中的梦想是做一只马、狗、猫、老鼠，四个叠成一列，你知道吗？然后有时候，我知道这是怎样的，我也知道这听起来怎么样，但我想象着做所有这四个，还在老鼠帽子的顶部放上一块奶酪。你不会觉得奶酪是最难的部分，但它们所有都喜欢奶酪。嗯，安迪确实问了，老鼠头上有什么东西吗？他说，是的，一顶小帽子。
And then Andy asks if the mouse has a name, and the man says it doesn't make sense to name the mice. That's right. And then Paul Figue improvised this line. They're kind of like cannon fodder, you know? You're not one of those PETA guys, are you? And then the cat jumps off the dog, and he's like, oh, great. We got a fan question from Karen T. in North Carolina who said, I need to know everything about the mouse, the cat, and the dog. How?
然后安迪问老鼠有没有名字，那个人说给老鼠起名字没有意义。没错。然后保罗·费格即兴发挥了这句台词。它们有点像炮灰，你知道吗？你不是那种善待动物组织的人吧？然后猫从狗身上跳下来，他说，哦，太好了。我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州的卡伦·T的一个粉丝提问，他说，我想知道关于老鼠、猫和狗的一切。怎么做到的？
And Lily B from Canada said, did the animals come from Bob Dunn's animal rentals? And did they already know how to do that? Or were they specifically trained to do it for this episode? Well, everyone, I'll have you know I went deep on this. I found out everything about how they stacked these animals. I personally love animal stacking. Yeah, I feel like you should share about this, like how I love when animals are dressed as other animals. Like if you dress your dog to look like a bunny.
来自加拿大的莉莉·B说，这些动物是来自鲍勃·邓恩动物租赁公司吗？它们以前就会那样做吗？还是为了这一集专门训练它们的？各位，告诉你们吧，我深入研究了这个。我查清了关于他们是如何把这些动物叠在一起的一切。我个人非常喜欢动物堆叠。是的，我觉得你应该分享一下这个，就像我喜欢动物打扮成其他动物一样。比如如果你把你的狗打扮成兔子的样子。
Yes. Like for Halloween, I love that. I love pictures of animals stacked on other animals' paintings. And oddly, I have a baby. painting of animals stacked on each other. I know. My friend Alex and I, we both love animal stacking. We send each other pictures of different stacks of animals. You know what? I love any video of like a cat on top of a goat or like a dog on top of a cow. I don't know. I just like it when they ride on one another. I don't know. What's your favorite animal stacking that you've seen?
是的。就像万圣节那样，我很喜欢。我喜欢动物叠在其他动物身上的画作。真奇怪，我有一幅动物互相叠在一起的婴儿画。我知道。我和我的朋友亚历克斯，我们都喜欢动物堆叠。我们互相发送不同动物堆叠的照片。你知道吗？我喜欢任何猫骑在山羊身上或者狗骑在奶牛身上的视频。我不知道。我就是喜欢它们骑在彼此身上的样子。我不知道。你见过最喜欢的动物堆叠是什么？
Oh, that's a good question. There was this video. I saw of this cat that used to love to go out into this herd of sheep and just ride around on their backs. Oh, that's cute. It just, and it loved them. But sometimes it would just take a nap on top of a sheep and clean itself. I love it when animals are friends with each other. Right. We should say you like it when animals choose to be stacked.
哦，那是个好问题。有这样一个视频，我看到一只猫，它以前特别喜欢跑到羊群里，直接趴在它们的背上到处溜达。哦，那太可爱了。它就是、而且它很喜欢它们。但有时候它就会直接趴在羊背上打个盹，顺便清理一下毛发。我太喜欢动物之间做朋友了。对。我们应该说，你喜欢动物选择叠罗汉。施压叠罗汉
Oh, yes. Right. Right. Not for stacking. I don't love force stacking, no. As for the fan questions, yes, the dog cat mouse came from Bob Dunn's animals, and yes, they were specifically trained for this episode. Here's how it happened. When Steve Burgess got this script, he reached out to Bob Duns, and he sent them a video of a real dog cat mouse that the writers had seen.
哦，对的。没错。没错。不是那种强迫叠罗汉。我不喜欢强行叠罗汉，不。至于粉丝提问，是的，那只狗、猫和老鼠确实来自鲍勃·邓恩动物公司，而且是的，它们是专门为这一集进行训练的。事情是这样的。当史蒂夫·伯吉斯拿到这个剧本时，他联系了鲍勃·邓恩，发给他们一段真正的狗、猫、老鼠的视频，那是编剧们之前见过的。
I googled it. There is a very famous dog cat mouse man from Bisbee, Arizona. Oh. His name is Greg Pike. and he will set up on a sidewalk with his dog cat mouse, and he'll accept donations from anyone who wants to take a picture with them. His dog's name is booger, his cat's name is kitty, and his mouse's name is mousy, and they all stand together.
我当时还去谷歌了一下。亚利桑那州比斯比有一个非常著名的“狗猫鼠”艺人。哦。他的名字叫格雷格·派克。他会带着他的狗、猫、老鼠在人行道上摆摊，然后接受任何想跟它们合影的人的捐款。他的狗叫布格，猫叫基蒂，老鼠叫毛西，它们全都乖乖地站在一起。
So this might have been the inspiration. Got it. And the town loves him. The town loves Greg and his animal stack. Steve said that Bob Duns initially offered a stack of dog cat rat. rats are very smart and they're very easy to train they sent over a picture of what a dog cat rat might look like and the writers really wanted a mouse yeah i don't know like a mouse is so tiny it kind of like then the little top hat's even tinier it even show smaller yeah well Steve wrote to them and said hey we would really like to try for a mouse on top of the cat
所以这可能就是灵感来源。原来如此。这个小镇非常喜欢他。镇上的人都很喜欢格雷格和他的动物叠罗汉。史蒂夫说，鲍勃·邓恩最初提供的是一只狗、一只猫和一只大鼠。大鼠非常聪明，而且非常容易训练，他们还发来了一张狗、猫、大鼠组合可能长什么样的照片，但编剧们其实更想要一只老鼠。对，我不知道，就像老鼠太小了，甚至连那顶小礼帽都显得更小，甚至看起来更小了。好吧，史蒂夫写信给他们说：“嘿，我们真的很想尝试在猫上面放一只老鼠。”
the rat could be a backup, but our first choice is mouse. These are the emails, Steve Burgess writes. Bob Dunn wrote back, Steve, mouse's first choice, we'll let the mouse know. That's what he wrote back. Well, Angie, I have even more information to share because remember when I did that AT&T commercial and there was that pug from Bob Duns? I told them, I am going to reach out to you for this podcast while I reached out. I said, how did you stack these animals?
大鼠可以作为备用，但我们的首选是老鼠。这些就是那些邮件，史蒂夫·邓恩写道。鲍勃·邓恩回信说：“史蒂夫，老鼠是首选，我们会通知老鼠的。”他就是这么回信的。好吧，安吉，我还有更多的信息要分享，因为还记得我拍那个AT&T广告的时候，里面有鲍勃·邓恩公司的一只巴哥犬吗？我告诉他们，我为了这个播客要联系你们，当我联系他们的时候，我问：“你们是怎么把这些动物叠起来的？”
Well, Mike Morris, the head animal trainer at Bob Duns, wrote me back and said this. Hello, even though I didn't do this job myself, I remember it vividly because it was such a funny scene, and it was really fun for the trainers to prep, and I was around while they were prepping for the shoot day. He said, many times productions come up with an idea that requires a specific look or an exact animal type, and other times they have specific action requirements. He said we did not have animals who were ready to be stacked, but what we did have were animals that were continually being trained to learn new behaviors as needed.
好吧，鲍勃·邓恩公司的首席动物训练师迈克·莫里斯给我回信说：你好，尽管我自己没有做这份工作，但我对它印象深刻，因为这是一个非常有趣的场景，训练师们在准备时也觉得非常开心，而且在拍摄日前的筹备期间我也在场。他说，很多时候，制片方会提出一个需要特定外观或确切动物种类的想法，而其他时候，他们则有具体的动作要求。他说，我们当时并没有准备好随时可以叠罗汉的动物，但我们拥有的是那些为了应对需要而不断接受新行为训练的动物。
And a lot of the basics are the same. So in order to do this particular scene, he said we would have looked for a veteran animal cat and dog, really well-trained, calm animals. He said it took about three days to prep. He said the mice, they had to start from school. scratch. And it would start with a group of mice and people would just handle them and get them really comfortable around people. And they would prep multiple mice and ultimately they selected
而且很多基础训练都是相通的。所以为了完成这个特定的场景，他说我们会寻找一只经验丰富的猫和狗，也就是那些训练极其有素、性格温顺的动物。他说筹备工作大约花了三天时间。他说老鼠的话，它们必须从零开始。一切从头开始。这需要从一群老鼠开始，由专人进行安抚并让它们完全适应人类。他们会训练多只老鼠，最终挑选出
the one that was the most comfortable on the shoot day. He said they prepped them in groups. They did a mouse cat prep and a cat dog prep. And then they would bring them all together. Steve Burgess added that they specifically chose animals with contrasting fur colors so that they would show up more. I guess the original video that they had sent, the animals were kind of the same colors, so they were harder to distinguish. They got a pop on TV. Yeah, that's right. They also put a harness on the dog so that when the cat sat on top of the dog, the cat's claws wouldn't dig into the dog in any way. Yeah, that's smart. He said you couldn't see the harness because the dog's fur covered it up. Steve said the hardest part was getting the mouse to stay on top of the cat, as you could
在拍摄当天表现得最淡定的那一只。他说他们是成组进行训练的。他们做了鼠猫组合训练和猫狗组合训练。然后把它们全部聚到一起。史蒂夫·伯吉斯补充说，他们特意挑选了毛色对比鲜明的动物，这样它们会更显眼。我猜他们最初发过去的视频里，那些动物的毛色差不多，所以很难分辨。它们在电视上要能跳脱出来。对，没错。他们还在狗身上套了个背带，这样当猫坐在狗背上时，猫的爪子无论如何都不会抓伤狗。对，这很聪明。他说你看不到背带，因为狗的毛把它遮住了。史蒂夫说最难的部分是让老鼠乖乖待在猫背上，正如你所
imagine. And the total cost for this animal training and this shoot day was around $10,000. Well, they pulled it off. I mean, it's hilarious. And we asked Matt Stone about all of this, about getting to work with Paul Feig, and then about the whole stacking scene. Here's what he had to say. I was very excited to get to direct Paul. It was also really fun because we got to pick out this suit for him. And for those who don't know, Paul, all. always wears the most fashionable suits. And it was fun to find this corduroy suit that our wardrobe department found and put him in. He looked great.
想象的那样。这次动物训练和拍摄日的总费用大约是1,0000美元。好吧，他们确实做到了。我的意思是，这太搞笑了。我们向马特·斯通询问了所有这些事情，关于能与保罗·费格合作，以及关于整个叠罗汉的场景。他是这么说的。能指导保罗让我感到非常兴奋。这也真的很有趣，因为我们得为他挑选这套西装。对于那些不知道的人来说，保罗一直都穿着最时髦的西装。而且能找到这套由我们服装部门找到并让他穿上的灯芯绒西装，真的很有趣。他看起来太棒了。
So he had his act, the dog cat mouse. I know that Paul had a lot of fun with the scene. And it took us a little while to shoot because we had to get the right angle that sold all of these moments. because the mouse was so small, the dog was so big. Of course, the cat was right there in between, but it all ultimately worked out well and was very funny. And the final moment with the cat was sort of a happy accident. You know, we were shooting every bit of the moment of the mouse staying on top of the cat,
所以他有了他的演员组合——狗、猫和老鼠。我知道保罗对这个场景感到非常开心。我们拍了好一会儿，因为我们必须找到能完美呈现所有这些精彩瞬间的合适角度。因为老鼠太小了，狗太大了。当然，猫就夹在中间，但最终一切都进展得很顺利，而且非常搞笑。最后猫的那一刻算是一个快乐的意外。你知道，我们当时在拍摄老鼠待在猫背上、
on top of the dog, so we could have as many options. to choose from in the edit. And, you know, it truly was that happy accident that the cat jumped off of the dog and the mouse stayed on the cat's back. And then I think the end of the episode is also very funny in that the cat is just chewing on the mouse hat,
待在狗背上的每一个瞬间，这样我们在剪辑时就能有尽可能多的选择。而且，你知道，那真的算是一个快乐的意外：猫从狗身上跳了下去，而老鼠却留在了猫的背上。然后我觉得这一集的结尾也非常搞笑，因为猫一直在啃那顶老鼠帽子，
which quietly leads us to believe that the cat has yet again eaten another man. mouse. I thought it was amazing that the mouse stayed on the cat when the cat jumped off. I know. Well done, mouse actor. Yes. Way to roll with some improv there. Should we check on the guys on their sales call? Yeah, well, they've arrived at their destination and Stanley is starting to wake up. Dwight's trying to explain what we're about to do, but Stanley is very, very loopy. This is when Dwight says, Clark, I guess you have to be Stanley.
这悄悄地让我们觉得，这只猫是不是又吃掉了另一个人。老鼠。我觉得最神奇的是，当猫跳下去的时候，老鼠竟然还稳稳地待在猫身上。我知道。干得漂亮，老鼠演员。是的。真会临场发挥。我们要不要去看看那两个出差销售的家伙？好吧，他们已经到达目的地了，斯坦利也开始醒过来了。德怀特正试图解释我们接下来要做什么，但斯坦利整个人迷迷糊糊的。这时德怀特说：“克拉克，我想你今天得扮演斯坦利了。”
today. And then Clark is like, can I remind you that Stanley's sister is best friends with this client? I can't say I'm Stanley. Yeah. And then Dwight's like, back to the old plan. We've got to get Stanley some coffee. Now, during this whole scene, there's a moment where Stanley looks over in the parking lot and he goes, pigeons. He like sees some pigeons. That was scripted. We brought in those pigeons and they required two animal wranglers. Imagine those emails. I know. I know. Please keep the pigeons away from the cat. Dog and mouse that are also working today. No kidding. Well, back in the couple's counseling, Pam is going to tell Nellie that she just doesn't want Jim to do athlete anymore. She doesn't want to give them an ultimatum, but she doesn't
然后克拉克就说：“我能提醒你一下吗，斯坦利的姐姐和这个客户是好朋友？我不能说我就是斯坦利。”然后德怀特就说：“回到老计划上来。我们得给斯坦利弄点咖啡。”好了，在整个场景中，有一个时刻，斯坦利朝停车场看去，然后他说：“鸽子。”他好像看到了一些鸽子。那是剧本里写好的。我们找来了那些鸽子，它们需要两个动物管理员。想象一下那些邮件。我知道。我知道。请让鸽子远离今天也要工作的猫、狗和老鼠。开玩笑吧。好吧，镜头转回婚姻咨询室，帕姆打算告诉内莉，她只是不想让吉姆再当运动员了。她不想向他们下最后通牒，但她也
want to move her family to Philly. And Jim says they're going to need a lot more than counseling if Pam won't move to Philly. We then see a scene of Jim and Pam. They're walking to their car and Jim kind of strokes Pam's back and they get in. And this really somber for the Jim and Pam fandom. Nellie and Toby have now done being couples counselors and I think it bonded them. They're both like, oh, those two are made for each other, blah, blah, blah. I know. They're definitely bonding. Yeah. It's a snarky bond. Now we're going to go into this meeting, and you wouldn't believe it, but Stanley is going to manage to make this sale. Well, he's happy. He's commenting on how cute this woman's grandchildren are. They talk about how if you push the nose, it goes, beep. And Stanley is just really having a great time. Yes. I thought the woman who played Mrs. Davis, her name is Deborah Lee, was just so real and so believable, because it's going to be a stretch for you to believe that Stanley's going to pull this off. And she was so genuinely.
不想把家人搬到费城去。吉姆则说，如果帕姆不肯搬到费城，他们需要的可远不止是咨询。接着我们看到一个吉姆和帕姆的场景。他们正走向汽车，吉姆顺手摸了摸帕姆的背，然后他们上了车。这对于吉姆和帕姆的粉丝来说真的很伤感。内莉和托比现在已经结束婚姻咨询师的工作了，我觉得这拉近了他们的距离。他们俩都觉得：“哦，那两个人真是天生一对，巴拉巴拉巴拉。”我知道。他们确实在建立这种情感连接。是的。这是一种尖酸刻薄的连接。现在我们要进入这场会议了，你绝对想不到，斯坦利竟然成功谈成了这笔买卖。好吧，他很高兴。他正在评论这个女人的孙子有多可爱。他们谈论着如果捏一下鼻子，它就会发出“哔”的声音。斯坦利真的玩得很开心。是的。我觉得饰演戴维斯太太的那个女演员——她的名字叫黛博拉·李——表现得太真实、太可信了，因为你要相信斯坦利能搞定这件事，本来就有点勉强。而且她也确实是发自内心地
delighted by him. It totally worked. I loved it. And the three guys are going to leave this meeting, and they are high-fiving. Yeah. Dwight says, I may never be manager, but I may have just managed to get their most stubborn salesperson to close a sale with one of their biggest clients. Andy's big moment is about to happen. He's going to meet for the first time with a TV and film agent, Carla, and I need us to go over Carla's office. Okay. 18 minutes, 39 seconds. Our set designers knocked it out of the park. Carla loves some knickknacks. Here are things I spotted on her desk.
被他逗得很开心。这完全奏效了。我太喜欢了。然后这三个家伙走出会议室，开始击掌庆贺。是的。德怀特说：“我可能永远也当不上经理，但我刚刚成功让最顽固的销售员和他们最大的客户之一做成了生意的。”安迪的高光时刻就要上演了。他将第一次与电视和电影经纪人卡拉会面，我需要我们过一下卡拉的办公室。好的。18分39秒。我们的布景设计简直绝了。卡拉很喜欢各种小摆件。以下是我在她桌上发现的东西。
Did anyone else catch the Magic 8 ball? No. Yes. We have a Magic 8 ball on every desk almost. She also has a bowl of mints, some type of, like, fancy bowl with the lid, some crystals, a lot of scripts, a pottery thing holding her pins.
还有谁注意到了那个魔幻8球？没有。看到了。我们几乎每张桌子上都有一个魔幻8球。她还有一个薄荷糖碗、某种带有盖子的精美碗、一些水晶、许多剧本，还有一个用来插笔的陶罐。
Behind her, it looks like she has maybe like a bottle of scotch with a fancy glass, a basket of fake flowers, binders, and they're titled, The Talent Agents Categories of Character Actors. Oh. Mm-hmm. Then she's got some bedazzled sunglasses, a tiara, a gold elephant statue that is holding a clock. She also has on her other bookshelf a sculpture, a framed dollar bill, a white roller
在她身后，看起来好像有一瓶装着精美玻璃杯的苏格兰威士忌、一篮假花、文件夹，上面写着“明星经纪人的性格演员分类”。哦。嗯哼。然后她还有一些镶钻太阳镜、一顶王冠、一尊手里拿着时钟的金色大象雕塑。她的另一个书架上还有一个雕塑、一张装在框里的美元钞票、一个白色的轮滑
skate, some stacking dolls, a lot of books, and a whole wall of photos of. some of her clients. And there was so much more that I didn't even capture, but this office really paints a picture. I believed it. I did too. And he's going to begin his interview with Carla by speaking in a British accent. But he's clearly tried to figure out all of these sort of sayings. Like he's like, ain't it? And he's sort of like, she asked him to list his talents. And he's sort of like, and one of my talents is that I can speak in a British accent and he switches to American accent. My favorite moment of the scene is that Carla's response
鞋、一套套娃、许多书，以及一整面贴着她的一些客户照片的墙。还有更多我甚至都没拍到的东西，但这个办公室真的很有画面感。我相信了。我也是。他将通过模仿英国口音来开始他对卡拉的面试。但他显然试图弄懂所有这些类似的说辞。就像他说“不是吗（ain't it）”之类的。而且她让他列出自己的才华。他大概就说：“我的才华之一就是我会说英国口音”，然后他就切换回了美国口音。我这一场中最喜欢的时刻是卡拉的反应
to this accent reveal is to simply say, can you drive a car? She comments in no way on his accent doing. And then she says, I mean, can you like juggling crap? I know. I don't know why, but her saying, can you drive a car? It made me laugh for so long I had to pause. We should say, of course, that Carla Fern was played by Roseanne.
对于这种口音暴露，她只是简单地问了一句：“你会开车吗？”她完全没有对他的口音表演做出任何评价。然后她说：“我是说，你会玩杂耍之类的烂玩意吗？”我知道。我不知道为什么，但她说“你会开车吗”这句话让我笑了好久，以至于我都不得不按暂停键。我们当然应该说，卡拉·费恩由罗斯安饰演。
Matt Sone said that she came in very prepared, and it was a really fun day working with her. She's going to appear in one more episode. She's going to go on to ask Andy, would he be willing to dress as a clown for a kid's birthday party and have pies thrown at him? He says yes. And then he thinks he didn't get an agent. But she says, oh, no, we're going to sign you. Yeah, she says pay Todd on the way out. Oh, you guys, you do not pay for representation. You do not. Acting 101. No. No. But the way Carla Fern's agency works is that Carla takes a flat rate of $5,000 up front.
马特·斯通说她来的时候做足了准备，和她合作是非常开心的一天。她还将在另外一集里出现。她接着问安迪，是否愿意为小孩子的生日派对打扮成小丑，并让人把派砸在他脸上？他回答说愿意。然后他以为自己没被经纪人选中。但她说：“哦，不，我们要签下你。”是的，她甚至说在出去的路上付给托德钱。哦，天哪，你们千万不要为代理权付钱。千万别。表演基础101。不。不。但卡拉·费恩经纪公司的运作方式是，卡拉预先收取5000美元的固定费用。
That does not include headshots. It does not. I wanted to let you know that Todd, the man collecting the check, was played by Ben Harris, who was Allison Jones's casting associate. That's right. We know. We know. new Ben, and this was a really fun way to get him in the show. And we got a fan question from Brooke S in Utah who said, I listened to Jenna's book for aspiring actors, even though it's not my goal in life. And Andy's process of getting an agent seems super different. Seems like there's a ton of red flags. Can you ladies share your experiences with getting an agent and any similarities or differences with Andy as he pursues stardom? I just want to hear all about what you ladies think of Andy and his experiences with this agent and starting out. Well, obviously, you know, agents represent you to help you get jobs. You don't pay them. They get a percentage of your income if they book you the job.
这不包括头像照。确实不包含。我想告诉你们，那个收支票的人托德由本·哈里斯饰演，他选角导演艾莉森·琼斯的选角助理。没错。我们知道。我们认识本，这真的是一个让他加入节目的非常有趣的方式。我们收到了来自犹他州的布鲁克·S的粉丝提问，她说：“我听了珍娜为有志演员写的书，尽管这不是我的人生目标。而安迪找经纪人的过程看起来超级不同。感觉里面有成吨的危险信号（红线）。两位女士能否分享一下你们找经纪人的经历，以及安迪在追求明星梦时与你们有哪些相似或不同之处？我只想听听两位女士对安迪以及他与这位经纪人刚开始合作时的看法的全部想法。”好吧，很显然，你知道的，经纪人代表你是为了帮你接工作。你不需要付钱给他们。如果你通过他们接到了工作，他们会从你的收入中抽取一部分佣金。
Yes. And that is a pretty standard amount. It's 10%. So if you ever meet with an agent who wants 25%, 35%, you're going to want to look elsewhere. But the hustle after they get you the appointment is up to you. You've got to do your homework. You've got to learn your lines. You've got to go in like a pro because ultimately they might get you in the door, but you have to get the job. You know, when I was looking for an agent, I ran into a few kind of scammy situations and I wrote about them in my book. What I would do is I would send my headshot and resume out to different agencies. Sure. You know, mostly small and medium-sized agencies since I was starting out. and you hope to get called in.
是的。这是一个相当标准的比例。通常是10%。所以如果你遇到的经纪人想要25%、35%的提成，那你就要赶紧另谋高就了。但是，在他们帮你安排了面试之后，接下来的拼搏就要靠你自己了。你必须做好功课。你必须背熟台词。你必须像个专业人士一样走进去，因为归根结底，他们或许能帮你敲开这扇门，但工作还得靠你自己去争取。你知道，当我寻找经纪人时，我遇到过一些有点像骗局的情况，我在书里写过这些。我当时做的是把我的头像照和简历寄给不同的经纪公司。当然。你知道的，因为我刚出道，所以寄的大多是中小型经纪公司。然后你就会希望能接到面试电话。
And I got called into one place and they said, oh, we want to represent you. But the first thing you're going to need to do is get new headshots. And we recommend you use this photographer. And it's the only photographer we used. And I realized that really what this was was just a way for them to make actors get photographs. So it was like they wouldn't represent you unless you got new photos. unless you used their photographer. And it was really just a photographer and a person who were kind of in cahoots.
我曾被一家机构叫去面试，他们说：“哦，我们想签你。但你首先需要做的事情就是去拍新的头像照。我们建议你用这个摄影师。”而且那是他们唯一合作的摄影师。我意识到这实际上只是他们迫使演员花钱拍照片的一种方式。也就是说，除非你拍新照片，否则他们就不会签你。除非你用他们的摄影师。这其实就是一个摄影师和一个中介狼狈为奸。
Yeah. Taking money from actors. And then in another instance, I had a meeting with it. I'm putting these in quotes, agent, who presented me with a contract, which is not unusual, totally cool to sign a contract. But there was a clause because you know I read it. Good for you. The whole thing.
是的。从演员身上捞钱。然后还有一次，我和一个——我把这个词加上引号——“经纪人”开了会，他给我递了一份合同，这并不罕见，签合同完全没问题。但里面有一条条款，因为你知道我把它读过了。真棒。整份合同都读了。
There was a clause that said that there was like every year there was an option. to renew the contract, it would automatically renew, but it was on their end only. And so it could become like this never-ending contract, which is also illegal. And the cool thing is that the Screen Actors Guild has a department that will review agent contracts for you and help you. And so I sent that contract to one of those representatives at the Screen Actors Guild, and they said, no, no, no, no, no. Do not sign that contract. That's great. I didn't know that. Yeah. So they were awesome and they were a great resource. But yeah, I mean, coming up, I had a lot of sketchy things that I had to kind of work out. And you so want that agent, just like Andy. You know, you so want that. And people will try to take advantage of that, you know? And so you have to be really smart and savvy and thoughtful. And you know what? It will eventually happen. It will.
里面有一条条款说，每年都有一个续签合同的选项，它会自动续签，但这完全是由他们单方面决定的。因此这就变成了一个没完没了的合同，这也是非法的。很酷的一点是，影视演员工会（SAG）有一个部门可以为你审查经纪人合同并提供帮助。于是我把那份合同发给了一位影视演员工会的代表，他们说：“不，不，不，不，不。千万不要签这份合同。”太棒了。我以前都不知道这个。是的。所以他们太棒了，是一个非常好的资源。但说实话，我在刚出道时，确实遇到过很多阴暗的事情，我必须想方设法去解决它们。你真的太渴望那个经纪人了，就像安迪一样。你知道，你太想要那个机会了。人们会利用这一点，你知道吗？所以你必须非常聪明、精明而且有头脑。你知道吗？这一切最终都会实现的。一定会的。
Yeah, and have good friends and people you can bounce the stuff off of. So if your excitement makes you blind to some red flags, your support group will catch them. Yes, 100%. Yeah. My favorite thing is one of the first agents I met with was this older guy and he looked at me and he said, you are not Hollywood glamorous. And I said, that's not what I'm going for. He was like, good that you know that. Did he end up representing you? Yes. How'd that go? Well, now Dwight and Clark are sort of filling Stanley in about this big sale that they made and that Stanley crushed it. And he's really happy about it.
是的，还要有好的朋友和能跟你商量事情的人。所以如果你的兴奋让你对某些危险信号视而不见，你的支持团队会帮你把它们抓出来。是的，百分之百。是的。我最喜欢的一件事是，我见过的第一批经纪人之一是个老头，他看着我，然后说：“你可不是好莱坞那种光芒四射的类型。”我说：“我走的本就不是那种路线。”他当时就说：“你能有这个自知之明很好。”他最后签下你了吗？签了。那结果怎么样？好吧，现在德怀特和克拉克正在向斯坦利汇报他们做成的那笔大买卖，以及斯坦利是如何大获成功的。他对此感到非常高兴。
So now it's time for them to go back upstairs. And Stanley's like, no, no, no. I'm going to go up the same way I came down. And he took the tranquilizer dart and put it in his thigh. Yeah. Down he went. Well, Matt Stone talked about this. final moment. Let's hear what he had to say. The episode ends with Stanley tranquilizing himself
所以现在是他们回楼上的时候了。斯坦利却说：“不，不，不。我要用我下来时的方式上去。”然后他把镇静剂飞镖扎进了自己的大腿里。是的。他直接倒下去了。好吧，马特·斯通谈到了这个最后的时刻。让我们听听他是怎么说的。这一集以斯坦利给自己注射镇静剂结束，
and then collapsing to the floor. I think originally in the script, it called for him truly falling forward or falling back. And, you know, we definitely wanted to sell Leslie doing this gag. We figured that the safest and easiest way was just to have him sort of collapse back on the wall and slide down. to end the episode. I think it all came out well. I think Leslie did a great job, and it was all very funny. This was a great episode for Leslie David Baker. He absolutely crushed it. It's a great, great episode. I'm really enjoying this last run of episodes. Me too. I'm trying not to get emotional about what's ahead, so this one was really fun. Well, a big thank you to Steve Burgess and to Mike over at Bob Duns.
然后瘫倒在地板上。我想剧本原本的要求是让他真正地向前倒或者向后倒。而且，你知道，我们绝对想把莱斯利表演这个搞笑包袱的效果拉满。我们琢磨着，最安全也最简单的方法就是让他顺着墙壁向后瘫倒，然后滑下去，以此来结束这一集。我觉得最终呈现的效果很好。我觉得莱斯利表现得非常棒，而且整个过程都非常搞笑。这对莱斯利·大卫·贝克来说是非常棒的一集。他简直绝了。这真的是非常非常棒的一集。我很享受这最后一季的剧集。我也是。我尽量不去对即将发生的事情感到情绪化，所以这一集真的很有趣。好吧，非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯以及鲍勃·邓恩公司的迈克。
Thank you so, so much. And to Matt Sown for those awesome audio clips and to the hilarious Leslie David Baker. Thanks for letting me interview you on our lunch break. And thanks to all of you for sending in your questions and comments. Although, Allie P from Idaho, I don't know if I can thank you for requesting that we try Stan Lee's morning three by five. But you did help to create one of the more memorable experiences of this podcast. All right, you guys, have a great week. See you next time.
非常非常感谢。还要感谢马特·斯通提供那些精彩的音频剪辑，以及搞笑的莱斯利·大卫·贝克。谢谢你允许我在午休时间接受采访。也感谢所有发送问题和评论的你们。不过，来自爱达荷州的艾莉·P，我不知道我该不该感谢你要求我们尝试斯坦利的晨间三乘五法则。但你确实帮忙创造了这个播客中最让人难忘的经历之一。好了，各位，祝你们度过愉快的一周。我们下期再见。
Listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Wise-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rupertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）出品的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制片人是艾因斯利·巴比科。奥德赛公司的执行制片人是珍娜·怀斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉坦的《鲁珀特树》。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。